Please welcome to the stage.
[inaudible]
I
was just thinking about stage,
trying to figure out what I'm going to
dive into because I use these folks as an
opportunity to the more deeply
into what I've been thinking about.
I'm going to talk to you about,
we spoke,
I wrote 12 rules for life.
Let me say it,
but I don't,
I'm not parroting the books.
No,
I'm trying to make what
I'm thinking about clearer.
I was thinking maybe a little
story before it can for the talk,
but what exactly is it that we're
going to address and I thought,
well,
I'm going to interest with
relationship between perception,
reality.
I thought that's a very serious problem
and it's so funny with the city at the
back of the stage and think back to them.
12 here,
welcome.
Like go and see [inaudible] listen
to be carved for 70 minutes about,
it's a philosophical discussion,
really psychological discussion as well.
The relationship between perception and
reality of who would have thought that
would be like a popular thing,
you know?
And so,
but I think it's a thing.
It's screening something.
Yeah.
Well reserve obviously a hunger that's
the unmet for some reason for serious his
and that's great.
So that's what we're going to do.
We're going to have some
written give tonight.
So
I'm going to stumble
around with a bit tonight.
I think because this is a very difficult
topic that I have gotten completely
clear in my head.
So,
uh,
hope you have to make this
as coherent as possible.
See if what I'm going to be trying to
solve at least to some degree is the
problem
of the relationship
between value and reality.
We live in a world of value where
things have gotten that material reality
itself cause the teeth to
have any intrinsic value,
right?
It's sort of,
it's there and so objective and in
some sense whatever value there is we
attribute to the world.
That's one way of looking at it anyways.
And that,
uh,
that that opens up questions
about the reality of value.
It also,
so that's one thing I want to address.
The problem I want to
address is how it is.
The perception is even possible because
the world is an insanely complicated
place.
Like it's so complicated that it's really,
it's really beyond comprehension
and so it is going is how it is to,
you can comprehend until that you
could perceive it because it's actually
beyond,
it's so complex.
It's beyond your ability to proceed.
So,
so I'm trying to solve two problems at
the same time is how in the world do you
manage this incredibly difficult job of
perception and what role does value that
the idea of value,
the idea that one thing is
worth more than another,
what role does that play in that?
You might say,
well why is that so relevant?
Well,
it's,
it's exactly relevant
because if the problems,
problem relevance,
you have to assume that one thing is more
important than another before you can
do anything.
Because to do something means that you
privileged that thing above all the other
things that you could be doing,
you value anymore.
So without imposing a value structure
on the world are discovering one within
the world.
I don't know which of those is true.
You can't eat an act if you have to add,
so you're stuck with it,
stuck with them.
It's not poured so much.
You start with the problem of value.
Okay,
so we're going to walk through them
and see if like I'm tangled up.
And there's,
I guess the third issue too,
we just given that you have
to value things in order to,
after that you have to act in
what should you fail you and so,
and how is that related to tell
you should perceive the world.
Okay,
so that's the kind of press,
the problem space,
let's say that we're going to investigate,
and this is related to chapter 10 which
is beat precise in your speech was just
an attempt in 12 rules for
life to lay some of this out.
So the first thing I want to point out is,
is some peculiarities of Oak.
We perceive the world.
So we can tell the story first about
famous psychological experiment that was
run by Dan Simon.
I'm going to go through it pretty quickly.
It's an experiment that has to do with
a phenomenal that Simon called changed
blindness.
I don't think he invented the term.
I think it's supervised but doesn't have
it for our purposes or what Simon did.
He made this vision and
most of you have seen it.
I'd take,
he put six people in front of an
elevator in a psychology lab and uh,
he had three of them dressed in black,
300 dressed in wiping the black team,
Heather basketball.
And the white team had a basketball and
the way team was sort of dance around
and passing the basketball back and forth.
So it was black team.
They had their own basketball and
your job was coming to fill out,
sit down,
watch the video,
count the number of times with the
white teeth through the basketball,
back and forth.
Now it's all you have to do now.
So you,
you go to magic committed
your state of mind.
You do that.
So you've come to the lab,
you've come to participate
in the scientific experiment,
you've come to following instructions,
and you've come at least in principle
to demonstrate that you're capable of
doing all those things.
Right.
I'd be somewhat intimidating
to come into the lab like that.
And you want to do a good job and maybe
you want to do a good job because we
want to be a competent person.
And the reason I'm telling them all that
it's because you've got to think about
why you would follow the
instructions and you do.
Okay.
Because it turns out that the fact that
you follow the instructions is very,
very important in this
particular demonstration.
So you sit down in a video
unfolds trying to do,
the people in the any org are quite large,
like they still the whole street so
they're not way off in the distance.
That's important because what happens,
it's so Simon starts the video room rents
for about three minutes and the white
team is wound around folks in
the basketball and throwing
it back and forth and
you're watching them and you're competent.
One,
two,
three,
four and safety.
You're doing a fine job and
he'll turn into doing a fine job.
You run up the whole three minutes
and have the extra vendor says,
how many times did the way teams
are the basketball back and forth.
You say 16 and he says,
correct.
And he was thinking he
great day stuff now.
So,
and then he says,
well,
can you see anything peculiar when you say
no,
what do you mean peculiar?
He says,
well,
did you see the gorilla?
Right?
And,
and you say,
well what do you mean?
Did I see the gorilla?
There was no gorilla.
And so Simon says,
okay,
watch the video again,
this type don't count.
Sort of rewinds it plays it
like a minute into the video.
Three minute video.
This guy comes in front
of the left of the screen,
he's like six foot four.
He has a girl,
a signal,
it walks right into the
middle of the video,
right in the center and beats
his chest for five seconds,
like gorillas,
do these type of things.
And then he saw Joe's office.
No,
got you.
Just as if it's a cross.
He was soldiers out of beaches
chest quite confidently.
And then one just off to the side.
And about 60% of the people who
watch that video don't see the grill.
And so some of you have watched that
video and make you so the grill,
maybe you did it.
He,
that he made a follow up video for all
those people who thought they'd learned
their lesson the first time they
watched the video in this video.
The same thing happens except
when the gorilla comes out.
Now people are crying for that.
Ain't that caps the grill,
the curtains behind changed from red to
gold and one of the team players leaves.
And so,
you know,
he asks you to start
retrieving all smart vote,
whether or not you're sewing things
strange when you see the gorilla and he
rewinds it says,
yeah,
but you see the curt and change color.
But the curtain name,
not just the curve,
but that you missed that completely.
And it is the fact that someone left.
It's like,
so even when you know you're blind,
you're still blind.
And Simon's done stranger things to that.
So one of the experiments he did Harvard,
which is a great experiment,
is to put a camera on top of a building,
is building Hartford Yard,
which is,
uh,
the,
the basic central point from the campus.
And there's lots of people out there
to have an undergraduate going up to a
tourist for the map
and ask for directions.
Okay,
so now to undergraduate here,
tourists,
they're asking directions with the map.
Now over here,
there are two workmen and
holding the door like this.
So here's the door.
It's can't see the word,
right?
Cause the door covers,
there's one at the front
and one at the bat.
And so undergraduate tourist workman,
they walked right in between the
tourist and the undergraduate.
And then the undergrounds,
if he's asking for directions,
grabs the door and keeps on walking.
And one of the work grabs
the map of stands there.
So basically what he's
done is swap people.
And both 60% of the tourists who were
being asked for directions don't notice
that they're now talking
to a different person.
Great.
So well.
So that's how blind you are and you,
you are a staggeringly blind.
It's amazing that you can
make it in the world at all.
In fact,
most of what you've seen when you look
at the road is actually your memory and
not the world.
Because your brain uses your memory of
things to fill in what you don't see it
as we've already demonstrated
because you didn't see the gorilla.
God only knows what you're missing.
And that's the critical issue with regards
to that experiment is like who knows
what you're missing.
And the thing that's so crucial,
here's,
here's where value plays into it.
This is why maybe a case of
you follow the instructions.
It's like,
well why didn't you see the
gorilla announcer as well?
And you were counting the
basketballs and the question is,
well why were you
counting the basketballs?
And that's that is cause you
were following instructions.
And then the question is,
well,
why are you following instructions?
Instead of paying attention,
let's say to the gorilla,
which seems more relevant and say,
well why were you following
instructions anyways?
Well,
you're trying to be a
good experimental subject.
I guess maybe you're
trying not to look stupid,
you're trying to do the DAS property.
Why is that?
Well maybe you want to demonstrate
that you're a competent person.
So like why is that so important to you?
You see,
the reason I'm asking all these
questions is because the way that your
perception was structured in
that experiment is dependent
on all the values that
you brought to the perceptual
act and experience.
All of those things work.
Focusing your attention on what
it was that you focused on.
And that was the,
the balls and not the gorilla.
And so those are all issues of value.
The only reason that you've come to the
ball if it was because you thought that
was the most important thing
to do in that circumstance.
So that was what you valued above
all else in that circumstance.
And so what that shows is that what
you value determines what you see.
Now I should say,
I should just stand here and repeat
that phrase to you for the next hour and
then leave.
Right?
Because that's so,
it's so important that it's so mind
boggling that this experiment was a
bombshell in psychology for
a whole bunch of reasons,
but it was also a popular bombshell
because almost how many of you have seen
that video,
you know?
Yeah.
It was towards you,
right?
It's like how many other psychology
experiment videos that you've watched?
Like zero.
This one,
everyone who's watched and
now no other questions.
Have you watched the old by anyone ever,
and so that just shows you how
I've seen the mind boggling.
This is almost not exactly,
it's not me.
It's so shocking.
It can be the case,
but it's actually even more shocking than
just the revelation that you're blind
because that's bad.
Not because you think,
of course I'd seen the gap grill.
It's like,
no,
you go and buy.
But that isn't even a
thing that's most my,
but what's most of the most mind boggling
in it about it is that it was the best
illustration that psychologist had ever
managed about in some sense about the
structure of perception.
But even more importantly about the fact
that your perception is conditioned by
your values.
And so we're going to delve into that
a little bit because the thing is,
what are the things you
might ask yourself is
if you miss the gorilla,
we also use music.
And then you might ask yourself,
well,
are you missing something in your life?
And you know,
the answer to them is often yes.
And then the question arises,
well,
if you're missing something in your life,
maybe you're aiming at the wrong thing.
If you're valuing the wrong thing,
so you're blind to what you need.
And the world is very complicated place.
There's lots in it.
And if you're missing something important,
it might be because you're not eating,
you'd have the right thing.
Like,
and it really might be that.
That's the thing.
That's what they meant.
So deadly about that experiment.
Now that is the only thing that
experiment isn't the only experiments that
experiment that demonstrates
this sort of thing.
There's convergent evidence supporting
this line of thinking for all sorts of
disparate areas of psychology,
psychology,
perception.
So,
um,
the first other piece of evidence is this.
You have the music,
perceptual resources.
And so especially for vision,
because vision is really,
really narrowly intensive.
So you mostly,
when you look at the world,
we mostly use the center of your eye.
It's called the fold the on and lets
the high resolution part of your eye.
Now you know the difference between a
high resolution and a low resolution
image.
A high resolution image has lots of
Fiji on a low resolution image has less
detailed.
So if you look straight ahead,
electrify,
look at,
and maybe I'll look at you so I
can see your face quite clear.
I know you have a face but I can't see it.
You,
you're just a blur.
You I can just see the fact that
your face is like your shirt is dark.
I can't see you people at all.
I know you're there.
I can,
I'm not letting my eyes cream tonight
really can't see you people at all either.
So my digital space is
limited to about that much.
And the part,
the sharp enough to actually see
a face is limited to your face.
Cause I can tell you have eyes,
especially if you move the,
because I'm pretty good at
detecting motion in my periphery,
but I can't tell anything else about,
you can't really,
I think your shirts blue,
I think it is.
So anyways,
now each of the neurons,
each of the cells in the phobia,
which is the high resolution department
connected to 10,000 cells in the primary
visual cortex.
And then they're connected
to infinite numbers of cells,
virtually about that.
The reason I'm telling you that is
because for the old tissue is neurally
expensive.
And so if I needed my whole visual field
to be as high resolution as my phobia,
that I'd have to have a head like at ain't
[inaudible] and that will be on doing
so.
Right?
So,
so what we do is we make
the most of what we,
what we have and we'd Gardner
eyes around all the time.
So we're just sticking around is around
like now taking snapshots of things and
stitching them together very quickly and
it gives us the illusion that we have
the complete field of vision.
It's not just an illusion,
you know,
because obviously you could walk across
the street most of the time to be hit by
anything that's moving too quickly.
So it's suffice is to keep you alive.
But there's way less of
that there that you think.
Now what I see in high resolution,
so what I using my valuable neurological
resources for is what I decided is
important.
And you can tell what I
decide is important by the
fact that I knew looking at
it,
right?
I'm choosing to point by
Isaac something of value.
Why else would I call it a point to my
eyes there that the mere fact that I'm
doing that is also an indication that
I organized my perception with a value
structure.
And here's something that's really cool
about people is because we want to look
at what's valuable,
right?
That that just seems kind of obvious
why you love what is valuable when you
could look at what's valuable.
So how do you ensure what's valuable?
Well,
sometimes through painful learning,
you learn what's going on,
what is it?
But with PE,
there's other tricks that we acquired.
Figure out what's valuable to Sosa.
Here's something cool about your eyes.
So you know,
you have a pupil and then
you have an iris around that.
It's colorful and you
have whites around that,
right?
But you're weird.
That rate,
because animals don't have
that even higher priorities.
The ones that are most
akin to us biologically,
they don't have that.
We do.
And the reason for that is I want
to see when you point your eyes,
and if you're Irish to stepping
out on a white background,
I can really tell who your eyes are
pointed and were unbelievably good.
It's figuring out where
people point their eyes.
Exactly.
When we interact with other people,
pretty much all you do
is look at their eyes.
Now it is.
Oh yeah.
Cause we look at their whole face cause
they're signaling emotions with the face
or returned to figure out what all these
other people that were looking to our
opportunity.
But part of the reason,
part of the way that we figured out what
they're up to is by inferring what they
think is valuable.
And the way that we infer what they think
is valuable is by watching where they
point thrice.
And people are really good at pointing.
Like if I pointed something,
which is like an extension of my vision,
if you have any sense,
you don't look at my finger,
you look at what I'm pointing out.
Now an animal will look
at your finger does.
It just doesn't get the whole,
there's something out there thing,
which is part of the reason [inaudible]
can't speak because the pointing
gestures,
prototypical speech it means signifies
an object of value in often that object
to go,
you would have a name.
So we point with our
eyes or things of value.
You can track people like this.
So there's a famous site,
social psychological experiments,
kind of,
uh,
you know,
casual experiment.
So imagine that you're,
uh,
you're the experiment.
This was done protective to go and all
you do is decided to stand on the corner
and look up like this.
It's on a busy street.
You know,
somebody walks by,
they're kind of thinking that you'll look
at that because there were two vague,
you go and you just keep looking up.
May Look at you,
they look up and they look at you again.
They looked up when they think,
well,
unless there's something wrong with you,
it must be something not that it is.
Why would you be standing
here looking at otherwise?
And so they feel that there must
be something important up there.
And so then they'll look and they'll
look at you to see what's going on.
And then of course there's
two of you located now.
And so we're going to drop there
must really be worth looking at.
And so then the next person
will come around and look to it.
So you get a crowd crowded people.
So if you're bored one
day and you're smoking,
smoking too much,
pause the [inaudible]
experiment about recorder,
you know,
so but credit.
But there's something,
there's something deep about that
too because this is how we infer the
motivation of other people.
This is how we understand that it as we
figure out what the hell they're going
to app and that helps us
even further value structure.
And if I can infer your values culture,
if I know what you find is important,
then I can read you as
a simulation online,
biological platform and I can infer
what you're thinking and feeling.
And that's how we understand each other.
That's how it works.
We actually do use avoidance and
computational platform to run this run
simulations of other people and we do
that by ensuring their value structure.
We do that,
but I got to get what they're looking
like trying to go what they're looking at
by trying to understand what
they think is important.
That's what you do with it moving,
right?
You go to a movie like what the hell
are you doing in a movie anyways?
Well,
it's entertaining.
that's not the question.
The question is why is it entertaining?
Why is it so important that you
align up at pay to watch it?
Like that's,
that's really we're thinking
about because you know,
it's strange behavior.
He fight.
It's so useful to you that you
find it intrinsically meaningful.
So much so that you'll pay for it.
Well,
unless what?
He would just put it your Thomas,
is it just like useless activity or eating
something that board or you're doing
something important.
You're going to,
to what's essentially a literary,
uh,
what would you call literary experience
because it's a story and you're locking
yourself on the protagonist and the other
characters and you're adopting their
value structure and you're embodying
that and you experience all the emotions
and all the motivations for no,
no,
no risk to yourself except the $14 that
you pay to be admitted to the theater
and you gain all that
experience vicarious.
And that's part of how
you understand the world.
And we're doing that with each other all
the time when it thinks we're trying to
do is to watch each other and figure
out what support to the other person so
that we can figure out what they're up
to so that we convert what support for us
so we can orient ourselves
property in the world.
It's a crucial,
crucial importance.
It's partly why stories
are so important to kids.
For example,
you could teach kids over
anything with the story,
you know,
will come running up to
you with a book and say,
read me a story.
We'd be a story,
maybe the same story 50 times what
we're trying to understand it.
That's how important it is.
It's absolutely crucial
and maybe it's crucial.
Some of you can,
you know,
you could distinguish
the gorillas from them,
from the basketballs
or something like that.
Okay.
So that's another piece of evidence that
we use our value structures to perceive
the world.
So that's took pieces of evidence.
Here's another way of looking at it.
So,
um,
if I'm looking at this landscape,
let's say on what we see in front of me
is going to depend on what I decide to
do.
So now it's not only what I see and
this is where it gets a little bit more
sophisticated.
It's not only what I see,
it's what I experienced.
It's broader than perception.
And with experience I would say what
motivates me and also what an experience
emotionally.
So here's a nice way of
understanding emotions.
It's very simple way and have
the relationship with perception.
So let's say I need to go over
offstage on that side of the stage.
And so if I'm standing here,
I have a clear path right to
the other side of the stage.
And that's actually going to have a small
effect on mine because once I decided
that going to the other side of the
stage is the valuable thing to do,
when I see a clear path in front of me
that produces a little burst of positive
emotion.
And the reason for that is that
people experience caused propulsion in
relationship to the likelihood that
they're going to attain a value goal.
This is also something that's worth
thinking about because you tend to think,
well,
you experienced cost promotion.
When you get something you want.
It's like,
well,
wait a second.
It's not so simple.
I mean,
let's say you want to have a promotion
at work and so you get the promotion.
Maybe have a party booked out,
but what happens the next day?
It's like what?
You're nervous both,
right?
Because you're not going to be word.
Now you have these new responsibilities,
so it sounds like you're
on cloud nine permanently,
or maybe you graduated from high
school and you're happy about that,
but the next day then you've
got a new set of problems.
The same if he graduates
from university here,
whenever you hit a good
milestone in your life,
it sounds like you're
there and that's that.
It's so that that that pleasure in the
attainment of a goal could be quite
fleeting because then you need another
goal and even the fact that you need
another goal after hitting
that goal to be a problem.
Like he might be depressed
after graduating from high
school cause you don't
know what to do next.
That happens to people all the time.
So it turns out technically that
the form of positive emotion,
positive meaning that's more reliable
than that is the positive emotion that's
associated with the feeling that
you're retaining a valuable goal.
How that's worth thinking about too.
Because what it means is that if you
want to the meaning of life that's
positively engaging,
then you have to be
pursuing the valuable goal.
And so,
and then we can tie that back to
the discussion at the beginning.
It's like what?
The way the world manifests
itself to you depends on your aim.
Okay.
And then if you're going to
experience positive emotions world,
you have to have a valuable aid.
And then there was a criminal,
they reach about June,
which is the more valuable your rating,
the more positive emotional experience.
While you're moving towards it.
And so with that would imply,
at least in part,
is you want to have the most valuable,
the impossible.
That's what it seems to me.
So then the question is,
well,
what's the most valuable?
A possible case.
So that's where we'll go next.
But,
but anyways,
one of the consequences of that,
even in the small and the microcosm that
say is that if you see a clear pathway
to a partial goal,
that gives you that boost
of positive emotion.
Now pause.
Depostion is also associated
with the act of moving forward.
So that's how your emotions
are tied to your voice.
So if you,
if you're pursuing something of value
and you have positive emotion that you
have to pursue it,
you're moving ahead and you know,
that's what you're saying when someone
says how you're doing and moving ahead in
life is that,
that's a positive thing to say,
right?
I'm kidding your hair.
Yeah,
that's a,
that's a positive thing as well.
It's like climbing up a hill.
That's a positive thing as well.
So we know that approaching something
moving forward is associated with positive
emotion stopping.
It's like that's what happens when
something happens that you don't expect.
So you're moving head towards a goal and
something you don't expect conference
or a threat to something dangerous.
You start that same anxiety.
Technically speaking,
anxiety stops because you get anxious
when you don't know what's going on.
You get anxious.
What you don't know.
If the path in front of you is clear,
they want and you should stop because
you don't know what's going to happen.
So that's,
and then,
and then to retreat,
that's associated say
with escaping from pain.
So you basically have three
modes of B move ahead.
It's pause.
If you stop and you get
over there and that's,
that's your whole and structure.
And so if you see a pathway
in front of you as clear,
it just something you valued,
they're not pushing the
positive emotion and your staff,
he moved forward forthright and they,
now,
if I'm standing here,
essentially it's just a little
more complicated because
there are things in the
way,
and that's actually in
some sense how I see them.
Obviously that's a chair
and that's a little stool.
And you might say,
well,
that's what those things are.
It's like,
yeah,
he's not so simple.
Exactly what they are.
For me right now,
there's minor legal obstacles.
It in the pathway to my goal.
And so they're dinged with a
little bit of negative emotion.
Now,
not too much because I
know I can just do this,
right?
So I could solve the problem that those
obstacles constituted so they don't
bother me very much.
One of the things that are being suggested
to people is that it's become a bit
of a need is that you should clean up
your room and that's caught on like what
the hell?
Why did that catch what everyone has
told you about since you were like one?
So it's a funny thing,
but,
but there's deep reasons for it.
It's like
your room.
Let's say you're in your room,
I dunno.
We'll see.
Are Your two hours a day just for the
sake of arguments and so that we can do a
little math there that says stupid mouth.
So that's 14 hours a week.
So that's,
that's one.
That's one day.
That's what they need in your life.
Footsie or wait for doing something
that is mandatory 14 hours a day.
So it's one seventh of your life.
And so in a,
in a year,
that would be a what?
40 50 days,
two months.
You're in your own for
two months every year.
So that's one seventh of your life.
And so it's all free to your room.
It's really one seventh of your life,
right?
You can think about it
as a material place,
that human habit,
it is that.
But that's not all it is.
It's a place that your experience is
localized for one seventh of your life.
And you might think,
well,
how you want that experience delayed.
So folks like,
well,
I didn't want the place to be
like an unruly hellhole so,
so imagine that you have
you things to do in there,
right?
You have things to do in their
work to maybe of thinking to do.
Maybe you have to get dressed so you
can present yourself to the world.
They get off to sleep.
I don't know.
Whatever it is.
If you're doing in your room,
maybe playing on your computer
to communicate with people.
Let's assume some of that is useful.
You know so well how do
you want to organize that?
And answer is you want to organize it
beautifully and efficiently because if you
do that and a good proportion of the
one seventh of your life that you're
spending in there,
there's going to be a bipolar.
And so if you organize that room,
at least it make it clean,
let's say that's the
minimum starting place,
make it clean.
Then the pathway to all those
things that you have to deal with,
that room that are
important becomes clear.
And then when you walk into the room
you're going to feel positive emotions,
that negative emotion,
you know this perfectly well,
you know you don't perfectly well.
I walked into your room,
there's your desk and there's a bunch of
things until their stacks of paper and
you haven't booked out with for like
three months and some of them are like
cats,
bills,
phone bills,
correspondence.
You haven't caught up with it.
God only knows what.
And some of those bills are
like older than they should be.
You think those were
just stacks of papers?
Of course they're not there.
They're not stacks of paper at all
except for the most trivial sets.
You're still annoyed with yourself and
so terrified of them and when you walk
into your room,
do you want me to book them?
Right?
You'll still,
you'll make a concerted effort not
to look at your desk and if you,
if your room gets cluttered
enough and if you get,
if your light's gets cluttered and outs
and everything around you will be like
that.
It's all cabled up pathways to hell
essentially distributed randomly Greeley
Rehab.
We really,
that serious hope is distributing sort
of randomly through your house and then
tower quarterly.
You're going to have reasonable,
productive,
meaningful,
beautiful experience if that's
how you set up your environment.
It's not your requirements,
it's an extension of you.
It's it can't think of it
any more clearly than that.
So with a behavioral psychologists
know perfectly well what going to take.
You could do.
If you want to get people to start
organizing themselves mentally,
he's to do something
like organize their desk,
right?
I mean,
I know some of you have idiosyncratically
cluttered desks and you know where
everything is and that's your weird
little style and maybe that works for you
all know,
probably mostly instructional
aid station Bas,
but
you know,
yeah,
that's just,
that's just the way I do it.
It's like,
yeah,
but you know,
if you take a take a
shot at organizing that,
making them pathways clear and things
clear up the front of you and the
probability that when you walk into
your room it's going to welcome.
You think,
well,
that's weird.
Wait,
you're looking at it,
the group create welcome you.
It's like,
really?
You've never been in a room
that's Bosco t it's just has,
you're not paying any attention.
I'm sure there's any theme in this
auditory who don't like certain rooms in
their house,
don't like going into them because
God only knows what's in there.
You know when you could feel
that emanating from those places.
Where do you store the hundred and 50,000
decisions that you should've made your
life that you didn't make in the forums
have stacks of things that you should
have attended two years ago.
If you don't think that it has any effect
on you and you've just dealt with your
senses to the point where you don't
notice because certainly has an effect on
you and you might also think,
well maybe you what we
want to clean up your room,
which is something you know
you want to make it beautiful,
how it means something even greater and
something I didn't write your voting
quotables life in product.
We'd be in the next book.
It's like you could take
it to the next step.
You could normally set up your room so
that you knew where your clothes were and
you knew why you were aware and you knew
who you were going to be when you more
and you set up the place that you slate
so that when you went to sleep you
slept.
So that B when you will
come to the morning,
like you were refreshed and
ready to take on the world.
So the whole place was pristine and it
reflected your discipline and then you
could make the bloody place beautiful
because you would learn how to do that.
You might take boats,
just my room.
It's like you're a wealthy man.
It hasn't been very long.
So it hasn't been very long at all in
the history of the world that people have
their own room.
It's a bloody miracle that you have that.
And especially with the
kind of rooms we have now,
and that's the case.
Even if you live in,
you know,
maybe the most talk,
the most desirable part of town,
you could still make that middle area
that you're responsible for something
bloody pristine and perfect.
And that would teach you how to make a
little corner of the world pristine and
perfect and that would
help you be that way.
And then you being that way,
he be rude being that way
with the ahead to your family.
Or they might have checked
what nab and he'd say,
grow,
wake her up to it.
So,
and then maybe from there you can start
to branch that out into the other things
that you're doing because these
are not trivial issues there.
They're very,
very fundamental issues.
So to want to make your,
make your room that you would have
the vast majority of the time into a
microcosm of the way that
you would like things to be.
It's an unbelievably useful exercise.
What's so cool about it is you can just
do it to practice right there in front
of you.
There's absolutely nothing stopping you
except your contempt for what you have.
And that's something you should
just dispense with entirely.
Because what's not helpful?
It's not helpful.
It's not accurate.
It's not psychologically useful.
It's,
it's counterproductive.
It's not good.
It's not.
We'll
only so,
so now let's,
let's,
let's go into this a bit more deeply.
So,
um,
one of the things I do with my students
when I'm feeling like torturing is
asking why,
why,
why they're,
why they're in class.
For example,
say you're trying to do an assignment,
say,
well,
why do you care?
You do.
Usually you can get about five ounces
of people with this line of questioning
before they run out of answers and
then they're not happy that you keep
questioning it because it's rude.
It's like when you care
about the assignment,
it's like,
well,
I need to hand in the assignment
to get a good grade in the course.
Why do you care about what they not?
You get a good grade in the course.
Well,
I need to,
I need to finish off this year universe.
Oh,
I need to do that.
Well,
I need to graduate and
and and have a degree.
Well,
why do you need to be fast?
And it's like,
well,
because I need to,
I need to get a job and support myself.
Well,
you get the basic idea.
Why do you need to do that as well?
I want to have a career.
Maybe I want to have a family.
It's like,
okay,
well why do you need to do that if
you keep asking that question now,
now what?
I'm what I'm pointing out
here is something that's
sort of analogous to what I
was pointing out when I was unblinded.
Why you went to the lab to begin
with and follow the instructions,
right?
There's a whole bunch of reasons that
are determining your behave and so when
you do something like maybe you're going
to a library and so we have to cross
the street.
If cross the street to the library,
when you have to get to the library to
pick up a book and you have to pick up a
book to study and you need
to study to pass the exam.
Then that nests inside all of those
other plans that I just described.
So normally do you have a need,
let's say,
but you have a name that's nested inside
of a bunch of other readers and so
that's how you focus your attention on
the world is I need to cross the street
because I need to go to the library
because I needed to get a book because I
need to study because I need to pass the
exam because I need to pass the course
because I need to get the degree so it's
like get a job so that I could take my
place in the community and what you,
what you notice is that with
each of those questions,
the area that you're eating
covers in terms of timing space,
that's the right way of
thinking about gets bigger,
right?
Because crossing the street that's like
the five second thing and going to the
library to get a bulk rate.
That's like a one hour thing and then
study a one week they your cortices,
a one month thing or three months they
are with each of those successive moves
out where outward you're describing a
series of agents that cover a larger area
of space and time.
So you can think about that as
your map of the space and time.
And that's a useful map because you live
in space and time and so you should map
and that's what you do with your value
structure because all of that's value,
right?
It's all assumption about what
it is that's necessary to do.
So then the question is,
well what is it necessary to do?
How far out can you push that step up?
Assumptions.
It's like,
well it's kind of pushed it out to well
I want to be a productive person who a
and I want to have a family
take [inaudible] well
maybe people stopped there
because they think at south,
but it's something like that.
It collapses into self evidence.
So it's rude bullshit.
It's like,
well it does.
It does.
Like what?
Cause you might ask,
well,
okay,
let's say you're going to
have a career and a family.
Um,
is there a map in which
that should be embedded?
And then the question would be,
one,
if you're going to have
a career to a family,
how should you go about doing
that in the best possible way?
Because I would be the next question.
At some point you're going to
run out of ability to question.
You're going to hit hit the
ultimate ends of the map.
I would say what seems to happen as far
as I can tell is that when you get out
that far in the line
of ethical questioning,
you start pictured that domain.
It's something like the story because
if you don't have an explicit answer
anymore,
just say,
well I'm going to have a family
and I couldn't have a career.
It was like,
well why are you going to do that?
Why is that an important thing to do?
Or how would you do that
if you did it right?
And then when you do what,
at some point when you run
out of explicit answers,
you start thinking about examples.
And you might think,
well that's where people
have already always done it.
That's when people I admire hooked up.
No,
that's what,
that's what my father did.
That was what my grandfather did.
Or I knew,
I knew people who took real
pride in their work and that's,
and that's how I want to conduct myself.
So you start to devolve,
what would you say your explicit
precept position started to shout into
something like stories.
And so that's where our explicit knowledge
meets the domain of the great story.
So what's the great story?
What's all that nested it?
This is where the discussion gets
more complicated and this is where,
this is where it would have
to dig to get this right.
Okay.
Have you tried to understand what it
means to act ethically and all that?
Starting with the presupposition that
that actually does mean something?
So you know,
in our modern world,
people tend towards a
kind of moral relativism.
They make the proposition
that there's many,
many ethical systems and it's very
difficult to adjudicate between them.
And maybe there's no ethical system that
has predominance over any other ethical
system.
Something like that.
But I don't buy that.
I don't think it's true at all.
I think that there's very limited number
of ways that you could make your way
through the world properly,
and that that's severely constraints.
The value system that you have to a dog,
let's say.
Well,
if you want to,
do,
you want to be,
if you want to be a family and
you want to do that properly,
let's say,
then how might you go about doing that?
Well,
let's see if we can,
we can take that apart and look a bit.
Uh,
I can use this as a,
as a means of,
of examples.
Okay.
You want to be a good father.
And so then imagine that one of the things
for the good father does is teach his
children how to behave properly.
So that's rule number five in my book,
right?
Don't let your children do anything
that makes you dislike them.
So I'm going to give you a sophisticated
example about how you might teach your
children to behave properly.
And that would be part of the structure
in which being a good parent would be
nested.
Okay.
So I'll tell you a little
story about hockey game.
I've watched once was a
cocky gate that my kid,
something was involved in it.
He was a pretty decent talked there
and he was on the book 13 when this was
happening.
But he used to go watch him play at least
those neighborhood lead and here's a
good hockey player.
But he wasn't the best
talking to bear and his team.
There's this other kid that was clearly
at the start and we were watching this,
the championship game and uh,
you know,
it was well if foc game
between well-matched dinged.
So that's a good thing.
Right?
Generally if you want
to watch a sports game,
weirdly enough,
do you want to see a well 14
between well-matched teams.
You don't want to see one team just
stomp the hell out of the other,
you know,
and have the game be 18 to
one it's not that sox fine.
Do you want to see the struggle?
I'm full and it been
relatively matched manner.
It's kind of interesting because it's
not obvious why you would want to see,
you know,
one team just,
beat to death,
so to speak by either,
maybe you could take some
gratification in that,
but if you have any sense you don't,
you want to see the team
struggle against each other.
You want the outcome to be,
to be too hard enough so
that it's uncertain and you
want to see the spectacle
unfold in real time.
And so that's what was happening.
So it was really good game.
And then in the last six,
seven seconds of the game,
real cliffhanger or something like that,
uh,
about six or seven seconds on
the kids from the opposing team.
Zicam ice can't beautiful
place or oppose goes the rent.
And that was the end of the
game and everybody cloud.
But you know,
the kids lined up and
shook each other's hands.
But the star on my son's team,
he was knocked out,
he was not happy.
He,
he was acting out the proposition
that he had been wrong.
And so he got off the ice and he took
his hockey stick and he smashed it up.
The spent them a little
tantrum and old and uh,
which was pretty pathetic.
His father,
seriously.
That's like,
what the hell?
And so then as far as father came rushing
up and his father was a preposterous
idea
and he basically agreed with this sub.
He said,
yeah,
you were abroad.
Did you played such as protection again,
you should one the referees took
it away from you and you know,
he was just some misbehaved
like two year old.
And then he rewarded
for it and reinforced.
It's like,
well,
one of the things that we
could hypothesize is that's
not a good way to be a
good to be good parents for that matter
is that in some manner he was damaging
his son and so,
and he paid for it.
It's like I didn't know
the guy a bad dude.
I watched how he conducted himself of the
chickens eventually came home to roost
as they inevitably do.
And so,
you know,
and so we'll keeps put
what was the problem here?
Exactly.
It's,
it's not so easy to take apart.
So think about his son was,
he was the best player on the team.
So I mean,
he's trying to win the game because
that's what you're supposed to do is
trigger.
But again,
if you're the best hockey
player in the teapot,
that's a kind of victory,
right?
And if you're trying to win,
well that's what you should be doing.
And if you don't,
we have it.
Why not be upset about it?
Because after all,
what you're trying to do is win.
And so,
but,
but you know all of them.
No,
we've know what your weaker moments,
you might act like that kid's father,
you know,
you know that that's not good.
So why,
why,
what exactly is going on?
And you might say to your kid,
well,
it doesn't matter whether you
win or lose your kindness over,
played the game.
And your kid thinks,
what do you mean by that?
And you say,
well,
I don't know,
but it's the right way to behave.
And it's like,
yeah,
you don't know,
but it is the right way to behave.
And so I can tell you why it's
the right way to behave and think.
And so it just goes along
with just chapter five.
But that your children do anything
that makes you just like so,
so imagine this.
So what is it exactly that you're trying
to do when you want your kid to win?
That's first of all,
you got to think about what do you
need by when we were in decided to do,
you don't need stomp your entity,
a team to nothing on in the hockey arena
because there's something about that.
It's just not exactly right.
Okay.
So,
uh,
what do you mean give me win this game?
Well,
no,
you don't exactly mean that
because life is APP game,
right?
It's a sequence of kings and probably
that it's a secrets of different games,
right?
And realizing that you're going
to be a pro hockey player,
just you're not,
so you might as well just
give up go hat cause it's,
you know,
it's just not going to happen.
But even if it does happen,
it's still a sequence of games.
It's not one thing.
It's a sequence of change.
But if you're a typical person,
and even if you're a pro hockey player,
hockey is just one of the many games you
come into play and you're going to play
those games with the same people
often over and over and over and over.
And so then you might say,
well the rules that govern the probability
that you'll win a set of games isn't
the same as the rule that governs whether
or not you would one of you should
never compromise your ability to prevail
in a set of games for the purpose of
winning a single game.
And so when you tell a kid
should be a good sport,
Kevin,
what you're saying is
that was the game has a sequel
haven has some important,
it's up to you to try and win cause you
don't find the playbooks as he tried to
win.
But this case is only part of a much
bigger thing and you're not trying to win
in this at the cost of
the much bigger thing.
That would be foolish.
And so what you actually want to do is
conduct yourself in the game in a variety
of ways that maximizes the
value of the whole set.
So you might say,
well let's say you're on a team
passed the damn pot now and then why?
Well,
cause you thought teammates and maybe
your whole team would be better to help
develop them.
So,
and maybe you could be the star,
you should try to be the
best player on the team,
but at the same time she did
it the whole team better.
So you know,
spend 30% of your time passing
the damn park to 700 kid.
So,
and then,
well,
you know,
that's also gonna show the other kids
that year or someone who's worthy of,
of,
of being on the team.
That's a really important thing because
you're going to be on the load of teams
and then as well,
if you conduct yourself properly while
you're playing the game and people
observe them,
then they're going to invite you
to play a bunch of other games.
And that's really what we
want for your kids at school.
Right?
If you think about it,
you don't want them to
be the best at a game.
You want the probability that people
will invite them throughout their life to
play in a whole series of interesting
games to be absolutely maximized because
then they'd never lacked opportunity that
think the whole world opens itself up
to them.
It's so what you're saying when you
say it doesn't have a human or lose it
matters how you played the game is conduct
yourself so that you have the highest
probability of preventative cross,
the whitest possible set of gauge.
And there's an ethic there and
there's a real ethic there.
It's real because it is really the
case that life is a set of games,
uh,
a very large set of the cage.
And it really is the case that there's
a way of playing a set of gauge that
maximizes the probability that you'll
be successful at the largest number of
games.
And it's very,
it's a very sophisticated ethic.
It's like,
and so I think I can
develop that a little bit.
It's like now you're trying to figure
out how to conduct yourself in the world
are going back to what's the
outside of the value structure.
How are you going to be a good parent?
You're going to teach your kid
how to play properly world.
You have to know how to play
properly in the world to do that.
So that's going to go along with it.
It's like,
well I'll,
how else might that outside,
uh,
ethical structure,
the parameterize that say,
well you want to play the game so that
you take care of yourself because you
need to take care of herself or someone
else has doing doesn't seem like a great
deal.
So you have to take care of
yourself and that's hard.
You know,
there's things you need your complicated
thing to propagate across time,
right?
So you have to take care of yourself,
but you have to take care of
yourself in a way that works today.
It doesn't interfere with tomorrow.
And so the today and tomorrow
don't interfere with the next week.
And so today,
tomorrow and next week don't interfere
with next month and next year.
Cause you're not just
taking care of yourself,
you're taking care of the set
of your possible future selves.
And that's way more
complicated and difficult.
And so you're parameterizing
what you have to do.
He,
there's an ethic Amanda,
but it's more stringent than map
because no man is an island this,
they say it.
So it isn't that you just
have to take care of yourself,
take care of yourself and your family
and you have to do that in a way so that
there's no interference
between the two of you.
And so that it propagates across time.
So that's really difficult.
And then you have take care of yourself
and your family in a way that absolutely
benefits the community.
And so that,
that makes it even harder.
And if there's no reason not to aim it
out because we'd be talking about what it
is that you should aim at,
it's like,
well you might as well aim at that because
there wasn't anything better that you
put a mat.
And we already decided
that piece to some degree,
that the way the world manifests
itself to you is dependent on what you,
a map and then you should aim
at the best possible vein.
And so now we're trying to figure
out what the best possible thing is.
There's a hypothesis there too,
which is the more you're willing
to aim at the best possible fame,
the better the world that
reveals itself to you is,
and you know,
you,
you kind of one of that,
I think you kind of know that already.
I would say part of the reason
you know that implicitly,
you know that in the same way
that you admire someone who's,
who's a good sport,
because you are,
that even if you watch pro,
if you watch pro sports,
of course inspiring people with skills,
there's no doubt about that and you
should because they're supposed to develop
their skills.
But the athlete who's top form and who's,
uh,
who's,
what would you say?
Who's a mature,
an honorable player that goes to the
people that shine above everyone else.
They have the skill,
but they have the nobility of character
and you put those two things together
and you think,
well there's an APP.
There was a role model
for young people as well,
so it's not just that
they could play the game,
suffer badly.
Although the candidates that they blame
the set of getting suffered and you
know,
you see that an athlete too who have
a real well real stellar reputation,
let's say stellar like a star because
that infers to starve course to start with
something that you have to lift up
your eyes above the earth to see it,
to look.
I want it to have it into a transcendent
space into something that twinkles in
the dark with the source of light to all
of that managed is part of what you use
when you describe someone as a star
and it's because you know placidly that
they're acting off his ethic.
That's part and parcel hopes
at the world's straight.
So soul.
That's quite remarkable.
That's all equipment.
I think this is like me.
It's all standards at least to some
degree out of the gorilla experiment,
right?
It's like,
why is it that you saw what you saw?
It depends on what you mean now.
It's like,
okay,
now that we've started figuring out
that what we see and what we emotionally
experiences associated
with what we aim at,
that we can start figuring out
just exactly what we should email.
And so here's the kind of thought
and I think it's a worthwhile one.
We'll do two things.
Well before this fight,
I didn't talk about how you
can get your aim street.
Here's disappears.
So I thought a lot about
the idea of meaning in life.
I wrote,
the first book I wrote was
called maps of meaning.
Exactly.
There was an attempt to
lay out the structure,
meaning as soon as that
such a thing existed,
um,
I derived some propositions as a
consequences of writing that book.
Um,
it's a very serious book.
It's all in audio form now.
Casey Richards did it came
out about three days ago.
So it's a hard book,
but I think it's a lot
easier to understand it.
It's spoken form because I could adequate
proper intonations to the complex
sentences and Abimelech due to the,
to the right and so if you like 12 rules
for life and if you're interested in
what I'm talking about tonight,
then you can give it a shot.
It's about 50 hours long.
I think that anything
in the spoken for form,
so it's very demanding.
It'll take you places that
are very much worth going.
Seriously,
please.
They,
they picked very much what's
going on as far as I'm concerned.
I'd be basing the lectures that I'd be
doing it for 30 years on that book and
the people that I brought along on the
journey that constitutes the lecture and
seek to think that it's
worthwhile as well.
So you could give it a
shot and it's a study.
It's a study of the meeting.
There's a set of
propositions in bedded in it.
One of the propositions is that
life is intrinsically and erratic,
deeply meaningful,
but the ineradicable meaning is negative.
Like the suffering people
are limited it mortal.
We all die like this.
Like let's go to a tragic element
that there's no arguing your cell of,
and so when people say is life meaningful
that it's what they need because the
negative part of life is right there and
you're going to experience it whether
you believe it or not,
when you're stepping
into a meeting or not,
that's nothing to do with whether or
not you're going to suffer pain and be
anxious.
That's going to happen regardless of
your rationalizations and so you're stuck
with that and you could consider that
some sense of a fundamental reality.
And I would say most transcendent
religious systems make exactly that claim.
So Judaism of course concentrates
on the trash the past.
Now I'm going to say he says all these
religious systems concentrate on one of
the first noble truth of Buddhism
is that life is suffering.
And then of course there's Christianity
and you are all familiar with the
central symbolic figure in Christianity,
which is the crucifix,
which is if that is the
representation of suffering,
then then you're not paying attention
to the religion because that's obviously
what it is.
In fact,
it's the worst time of suffering because
here's the worst time of suffering.
He saw her physically,
mentally,
right,
but the reason you suffer
is because people be traded
you and they'd be training
despite the fact that you're in this.
So it probably is it suffering
is the worst suffering,
which makes it
architectural in some sense.
It makes it a kind of suffering
that can't be exceeded.
So that that's why that simple has such,
it's one of many reasons that
that symbol has such power.
It's like,
okay,
so that's the bottle of wine.
That's the baseline structure of reality.
Let's say.
God,
that's so pessimistic.
It's like,
yeah,
that's for sure.
But what is it is,
it's unbelievable to be pessimistic,
but,
but the thing is is that you can't get
to what you need to get to until you get
to what you can barely tolerate.
That's a good way of thinking about it.
And you all know,
and I think part of the reasons perhaps
that you're here is because I'd be
talking about these sorts of
things in my lectures and my books,
and I'm not trying to pull any punches
like I do believe that everyone knows
that the claim that life is suffering,
and then it's tainted by malevolence by
the way in which even makes it worse,
right?
It's not just suffering.
It's not just the fact
that life is tragic,
that's bad enough,
but it's made worse by the fact
that no matter how bad things are,
or you can do something
stupid to make them worse,
and he probably not only will it have
you all know that because you know,
you know perfectly well
that when you're miserable,
I mean,
I know terrible things could just sort
of happen randomly and I understand that
perfectly well,
but you also know that many of the
most miserable moments in your life,
no doubt there is many of them.
You are accompanied by this sense that
you knew bloody well when you were
getting into it.
You weren't smart enough to stop it.
Or maybe you even facilitated or maybe
facilitated knowing that suffering was
going to be,
they'll come and say,
well to hell with it,
I'm going to do it anyways.
And so,
and you know,
or maybe it'd be betrayed by someone
cause that happens very often and maybe
you'd be traded some honor.
You aren't deceitfully or immorally by
your own moral standards by the way.
And so nothing so bad that
you can't make it worse.
Right?
And so it's not just that life is tragic
and it's also touched with malevolence
and that definitely makes it work.
So,
so that's your starting point.
It's like,
okay,
so that's about,
I'm as pessimistic as it gets.
And you know,
you do read dealt into
that you can look at,
I studied totalitarian brutality for
40 years I guess in Hawaii and I was
clinical psychologists,
just oil.
I still am.
But I've done thousands of hours of
clinical work and I've seen some pretty
nasty things of course studies and
things that were perhaps even worse.
And so it is definitely the case that
people can make it the mirror tragedy of
their life.
And just something very
much approximating hell.
Some of you probably from
families have done exactly that.
Or maybe you're in a family right
now that's doing exactly that.
It's like,
so in that step that takes a bad thing.
It makes it unbearable.
You know,
you've been thinking sometimes matching
people around the deathbed that the
family member,
right?
And there's all sorts of
unresolved family conflict.
And so isn't that not that the person's
laying there gasping up their last
breath,
but everybody in the room was hostile.
And let's say they're also arguing because
that's certainly a good time to have
an argument that it certainly happens.
Plenty of it.
So you can take stuff from that's pretty
damn bad and then you could turn it
into hail.
And so that's life.
You think,
well that's pessimistic.
It's like,
yes,
good means we've got to
the bottom of things.
That's a place that you
could start building and say,
all right,
fair enough.
It's like life could be like that.
So what that means is that
you need a reason to you.
You need a reason when things aren't good,
you need a reason to get
out of bed in the morning.
You need a reason to move forward
despite the fact that life is essentially
tragic and it's tainted by
malevolence and the question is,
is there anything that's up sufficient?
Grand jury I'd say are sufficient.
Nobility were sufficient solidity to be
of the 80 to you when you're facing with
the tragic malevolence of life and I
think the answer to that is yes and that's
why this isn't pessimistic because if you
could pose the worst possible question
but then you can answer
it with the proper answer,
then the question is no longer so bad.
Carl,
you said instruct
holiness in for the tour.
It's a Latin,
it means that which you most want and
will be followed where you least want to
look man,
that's a smart idea and then
actually happens to be wavering.
Look where your where was easy to look.
Yours is a book where you want it to look.
It's time to look where you don't want
to look and that's that sweeping for
sure.
It's like,
well,
we just look where we don't want to
look at this conversation at the darkest
part of life.
It's like,
well,
are we all do it?
If that's the fundamental
preconditions of life,
yes it is.
Are we up to it?
Well,
the answer that seems to be yes,
as a matter of fact,
but no matter how difficult life is,
and no matter how tragic the conditions,
no matter even the fact that it's made
worse by the malevolence of the human
spirit that say we're actually capable
of moving forward and prevailing under
such circumstances with our eyes,
I would say,
well,
the world reveals itself team in
accordance with your aims in the world.
So I can say,
well,
the world has this proclivity to
tilt towards tragedy and malevolence.
What are you going to
do with all the power?
You need the name.
But it's so remarkable that acting towards
it justifies the catastrophe of your
existence.
And you know,
I could put that in pro se form.
And you all know this is true too.
You need a reason to get out of bed in
the morning when things aren't good.
And things are in our thing to be good.
At some point,
you know you're,
there's going to be
illness in your family.
There's going to be the
collapse of your dreams.
There's going to be the pathology
of your state is or you're going to,
you're going to encounter all the
vicissitudes of life now just for sure,
and if your goal is to be happy,
well that's not going to get
you through the rough times.
That's for sure because you're not going
to be happy then and it's precisely
during the rough times that you need
to get through and maybe you can say to
yourself something like a,
look what I'm doing instead
is pursuing a noble.
The school like the possibly can see
robot going to take care of myself
properly.
I'm going to do that in a way if it's a
maybe a maximal benefit to my family and
aren't going to take care of myself and
my family in a way that it's a valuable
benefit to my community.
I'm going to take all those things
into account simultaneously.
And the reason I'm going to do that
is because I can push back against the
tragedy of the world and I could
constrain these malevolence.
I can do that in my own heart and I
can help the people around and do that.
And you can in fact do that.
Certainly you could make it worse.
That's absolutely undeniable and that's
actually a great place to start because
once you know that you can make it worse.
You know,
if these,
if you could see doing that well Brian,
well that's something,
right?
Even if you're not moving the world,
you know extraordinarily
rapidly towards Heather do,
you could move it at least be
somewhat quickly away from hell.
It gets the hell of it.
You're capable of producing
and it's not right.
That's nothing cause you
can cause a lot of trouble.
You have that firmly within your,
you have the power to
cause a lot of trouble.
You know that because you probably already
caused a lot of trouble now and then
and so you can at least stop doing that.
You could see that ability by
looking at capacity for destruction,
you can see what you're capable of.
And so that should give you some respect
for yourself and kind of a perverse
manner.
If you're that much of a
force for catastrophe and
managing what sort of course
for good you can be,
you might be enough of a force for good
to stand up as a whole arc against the
catastrophe.
And I would say,
well,
so all that deep pessimism for me,
some sense disappears because I
do look to people and I think man,
we got a rough,
like there's no doubt about it that this
is available with tears and we could
twist it into something
that's quite Hellige,
but there's enough nobility in each of
us so that we can actually work against
that and we can,
we can make the world less tragic.
But he said we can definitely
make it less bilevel in place.
And we did work on that,
like right in our local environments,
right?
We could make our rooms
clean and beautiful.
We can make our,
our family's pristine.
We can,
we can get our age,
we can,
we can shut our aim and we can live in
their eyes above the horizon aiming for
what's best.
We can do that.
And what's so fascinating
about Catholics say,
well that immediately infuse your life
with the kind of positive meaning that
they will sit down,
actually sustain the tragedy.
It's like I've done
something worthwhile to do.
You know,
nature said he who has
a why can bear any how.
I was like a brilliant phrase.
So you know,
one of the things are
we doing is traveling.
Come to me now,
look,
I am here talking to
people about exactly this,
talking to the promote them,
maximizing their responsibility.
They will because your life is
tragic as authority lay notes.
It's like,
and so you need a way or viewing that
with the richest possible meaning so that
you don't become corrupted and resentful,
angry and hostile and cruel and worse
as a consequence of the burden that you
have to bear that's placed upon us.
But keep it.
Take that on Roland terror you can take,
well,
I wouldn't do absolutely everything I
can to make absolutely everything around
me as good as I could possibly make and
not some naive virtue signaling way.
That is what I need.
I mean to take this on like this,
the task of your life and it
is the task of let your friend.
Then you think,
well,
what?
What would that make possible in this
world of art school were remarkable
creatures.
You know,
we're all in a nice appeal.
We're on a night,
South Hill trajectory,
ethical,
you know,
things all over the world are
getting better really quite quickly,
quite remarkably quickly.
You didn't know.
This isn't very well known because
of our deep current pessimism.
You know,
people are being lifted
out of poverty right now,
running the world and rape is absolutely
unprecedented in the history of
mankind.
Ha.
We lifted half the people who were in
absolute poverty in the year 2000 we're no
longer in absolute poverty by the
year 2012 that was more than him.
[inaudible] 300,000 a thousand
people a week.
Right now or be hooked to the power group
and people are getting access to fresh
water and the unprecedented rate and
infant mortality rates are declining
precipitously all over the world and the
world's fastest growing economies are
in sub Saharan Africa and no one is
starving anywhere unless someone is trying
to start with to death because there's
actually enough food for everyone and it
doesn't look like you're going to run out.
Our population's going to peak at about
9 billion and we can probably handle
that.
Especially given current growth
rates in agricultural production.
You know,
it's so we did move into this
future that lies in front of us,
especially with this technological
prowess that would be developing.
That's absolutely remarkable.
We could,
we could move into this future and God
only knows how much of the actual tragedy
of life we could push to the back of that.
How much is the malevolence that corrupts?
If he could obliterate,
who knows how good we could make things,
it would you think what your old bedroom
and twisted because life is difficult.
If he'd betrayed like look,
fair enough,
man.
Life is difficult.
And you probably didn't leave the
trade and what are you going to do?
I'm gonna make it worse.
Well,
that's not going to get
you up in the morning,
right?
That's going to make you want to,
who knows what that's going
to make you want to do.
It's not going to make you want
to do something that's good,
that's for sure.
Instead you can say,
well,
bring it on.
Like I can handle it.
Keep it except for one that voluntarily.
That's rule one quite the way.
Stand up straight with
your shoulders back.
That's the injunction.
It's like you can,
you can stand down and expose
yourself to the catastrophe.
That's the world.
You could take that arm
volunteerer as if there isn't,
if there's enough of you to manage it.
And the funny thing is,
the strange thing is,
is that,
and you know this already,
you know,
and if you're careful with yourself,
every time you take on
additional responsibility,
you grow more terror,
right?
That's how life works.
You don't get to grow more character
and strength without taking on the load.
You don't do that.
And then Jim Wright
develop your musculature.
We felt pushing the amount of
weight that you're lifting.
You can't just wish your
apostles into growth.
They have to demand that
they make themselves better.
Says,
oh,
your life is like that.
It's like,
well,
you have received calculable potential
that people are always calling you on.
You're not living up to your protection.
You don't moving up to your potential.
You say that to yourself and other people
say it too as well because they know
that he would hit you in some sense
is the ability to take the entire
catastrophe of the world on your shoulders
have to do everything you possibly
can to make it better.
And in that you find the meaning in life.
It makes all that to justify some of
that tragedy that maybe what you making,
I don't know if it
would make it desirable,
but it certainly makes it
acceptable as a church,
you need the challenge
and I think that the,
the possibilities that lay it open to us
perhaps more now than at any point you
can pastor virtually without limit.
And you know,
I would say that we're recruiting things
quite rapidly despite the fact that
we're actually stumbling
forth for quite blindly.
You know,
we can be more alert,
more awake and more committed to the good.
We are substantially a garland.
He knows how much we did accelerate what
we're doing and how good we can make
things.
And if you,
and if you're careful,
you could start that locally so
you don't cause too much trouble,
you can just figure out
what's wrong with you.
It just ask yourself,
you get a big list and then you can start
working on it point by point by bit.
Say,
look,
I'm going to make tomorrow a
little bit better than yesterday.
I'm going to do that iteratively get,
I'm going to do that every day and
I'm going to see what happens if I use
everything at my disposal to push back
against the catastrophe of the world.
Because maybe that would set things right.
And that's rule number six,
which is the one I'll close with.
Set your house in perfect order
before you criticize the world.
And so
[inaudible]
what there is to,
you know,
and if you take on the responsibility,
if you take on responsibility for the
fact that things aren't exactly how you
would want them to be and you've decided
to important to begin to set them
right,
it's possible that you mold
yourself across time into
precisely the person who's
capable of doing that.
And why wouldn't you?
That that's how it works.
And so it seems perfectly reasonable that
each of us could do that and god only
knows what would happen if we all did.
So it seems to me that it would be a
lovely thing for all of us to try and it's
a good time in the history of,
of our,
of our species,
let's say for us to wake
up and do precisely that.
So thank you.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
standing
up straight with your shoulders back.
Thank you.
Perfect.
A reasonable or I've been just a moment,
uh,
hopes of abusive in some
questions over the Internet.
We'll come back,
we'll have a seat.
We'll go into some of your questions.
We'll do about 30 minutes of Q and.
A.
Uh,
it has is going to be wonderful.
And then we have,
this is like the,
I don't know,
those 16th showing this
tour in every night.
Every lecture is different,
is just if you'd like to visit
us again and we've got to,
we're in the Minneapolis,
uh,
tomorrow night in Milwaukee,
Minneapolis up and then
a west coast swing.
And then we go a Canva in July.
So please feel free to join
us again for another lecture,
Dr. Peterson and be out here shortly.
And this is,
uh,
this is really a movement.
I think it's really,
it feels wonderful,
but you guys are here to z.
[inaudible]
are you guys ready for the Q and a
great job.
Okay,
so here's a question.
We'll start with this one.
Are you aware that today,
yes,
today is national law
or day [inaudible] no.
No.
I wasn't aware of [inaudible].
Okay.
So that's pretty damn funny.
So here's another thing.
Get this at all.
This is quite the street.
So are we trying to group how
to tie a Windsor Knot in my tie?
And so I just started that like two
days ago because I have this pit and tie
that does look quite pregnant,
total wins or not.
And then there's a question here that's,
that'd be just trying to
understand why the world was,
have you thought about
switching to the full Windsor?
Yes.
[inaudible] I don't know
what in the world to,
to,
she knows what to do about that,
that's for sure.
Okay.
Um,
you've accumulated fade so
quickly over the last few years.
You keep yourself humble.
And then there's some
other questions like,
which is quite similar,
which is,
um,
where do you do to protect yourself
from corruption since being put on a
pedestal?
What can do in the same situation?
Wow.
Okay.
So let's,
let's answer those.
Uh,
well,
I do these sorts of things that
I was talking about to you today.
You know,
I have an eight,
let's say that I've thought
through very deeply,
I mean,
when I wrote my first book,
which I told you about,
and I hope you have version maps,
VT,
um,
I thought about what
happened in Auschwitz.
I thought about it from the
perspective of a perpetrator,
not from the perspective
of a bystander or a victim.
Let's say.
I thought,
how is it that people could do what
was done in Auschwitz by the guards?
But I thought hope that
more specifically I thought,
how is it that that person who is human
could do that given that I'm also human
and I can't see how I could do that.
And then I thought about until I
could figure out how we could do it
and so,
and then I figured out that I could do,
then I figured out that I
could probably enjoy it.
And so that scared me enough so that I
figured out that I tried to see what the
answer to that one,
you know,
up as far away as possible.
And so I would say that part of what
I do to keep my feet on the ground,
which I written for the offense,
capacity for evil,
that every single one of
us is characterized by,
and I terrified enough with that,
that say to try to Orient
Myself property in the world,
say that fear of God is
the beginning of quiz.
That's a good way of thinking about,
you could say
people conceptualize let's say,
because if you want to keep
yourself on the up and up,
it's one thing to be ab for heaven,
but it's another thing
to be a big weights.
And I don't care how cynical you are,
you can be cynical enough so
that you don't believe in heaven.
There's no way you can be cynical enough
so that you don't believe in hell.
And so once I've established that
if you have any sense of the hall,
then at least you could
aim away from that.
And if that's what you're doing and you
know how deep that place where he is,
then that can help you keep
your feet on the ground.
That's what it looks up to me.
So that's one of the answers.
I try to eat as far away
from that as possible.
So that's part of what I laid up tonight.
Just like what am I trying to do?
Well,
I have my flaws and so no,
I'm not doing this perfectly,
but I'm dancing.
I'm trying to aim a week from that.
Tried to take care of herself,
trying to take care of herself in a
way that is maximally beneficial to buy
salmon.
And I'm trying to do both of them was
in a way that's maximally beneficial to
the community.
That's what I'm trying to do with.
The reason I'm trying to do that is
partly because that's the best way a wave
from hell sort of.
That's a pretty good start.
But I also feeling that because I can't
think of anything better possibly to do.
And so it's a immense
challenge to do that.
And you need a challenge,
right?
And so why not have that as a challenge?
And I've talked these things through.
They're not shallow commitments.
That doesn't mean that I'm
with error right there.
So then the other thing
that you have to do,
if you want to stop yourself for big,
corrupt it is you want to surround
yourself with the right people.
I know rule wonders stamp at straight
with your shoulders back rule to it's
treat yourself like you're someone
you're responsible for helping.
And we're all three years,
make friends with the people
who want the best for him.
And those aren't injunctions about
how to have a happier life there.
Injunctions about how to
act morally in the world.
You need to take care of yourself like
you're someone who's worthwhile and you
need to have people around
you view you in the same way.
That doesn't mean they're
letting you off the hook.
Quite the contrary.
And so I'm fortunate,
I have two kids,
they're both very sensible and their eyes
are open and they're watching what I'm
doing and if I make a mistake or they
don't make a mistake or not be cautious
enough,
they telling me why something takes
away my Twitter password all the time.
Yeah,
yeah,
no.
And you know,
I can get it back,
reset the password,
but it's how you relate to him too.
You know.
So I don't like traveling with my
wife and she keeps an eye on me.
She's,
she's always in the crowd and
she sees what's happening.
She's a sensible person that she's
picked tempered in your own inner fire.
So she watches and then I have friends
around me and an extended family and
they're all watching and
they are not hesitate.
They don't hesitate at all to do,
let me know if they think that
what I'm doing is working.
But if it's not working and
they take our greatest mistake,
it's like we have a phone call and they
told me exactly what they think I did
wrong and how are we going
to fix it and how you listen.
Because I don't want to do any more
things wrong than absolutely necessary.
And so I would say part of the reasons
that I keep my feet on the ground,
cause I hate to say I keep myself humble
because I don't want to claim that,
but I'm trying to keep
my feet on the ground.
Is because I'm properly
terrified of doing things wrong.
And so I'd do my best to be
very careful about what I say,
what I do,
and so far that has produced
any catastrophic consequences.
So parades of that.
So,
okay,
well
this is very serious.
I don't know if I should address
it because I was somewhat tired,
but I'll give it a shot because it's
important how it's very serious troubles.
I plan on taking my own lights very soon.
Why it should?
Well,
I'm going to sit.
This is a casual request,
you know,
let's be put out for
the purposes of display.
Well,
the first thing I would say is you have
to think very carefully through the
consequences of that for other people.
So I've had clients in my clinical
practice with never recovered from the
suicide of her family
member decades later.
They were still torturing
yourself above it.
And so that's what you leave behind.
Now,
problem is you might be dreaming.
Maybe you're feeling like this big twist
is against you and that people deserve
to suffer for the misery
that they imposed upon you.
That I would say think very,
very carefully before
you pull down that route.
It's a terrible thing to leave people
with and so part of the reason that
suicide has legal legally post societies
is because it absolutely devastates the
people you leave behind and
you might take what made,
you know,
if you're really depressed,
maybe you're really depressed.
That's a possibility.
He might take all those people
would be better off without me.
It's like it makes you
get really depressed,
you fatigue that way we can even get
to the point where you can't think any
other way that and would say if you're
at the point where you can't think any
other way than that,
that you should tell someone and you
should go to the hospital because that can
happen.
It can happen if you get depressed.
There are treatments for depression,
you know,
and many of them work for some people,
antidepressants,
work Matt out that don't work for
everyone and not claiming that they're a
panacea,
but they certainly beat
the hell out of suicide.
Right.
Even if they have some negative side
effects and sometimes they do quite
frequently they do.
The negative side effects aren't fatal.
It's like well are certainly there's a
possibility that that that your condition
is physical,
that you're ill in some way,
either physically or perhaps you have a
psychological problem and maybe you were
hurt her or,
I mean there's lots of reasons that
people get depressed that are very,
very complex.
I would say don't give up hope without,
don't give up hope and do something fine
up before you've explored all possible
the auctions and if you haven't
talked to a psychologist,
you haven't talked to a psychiatrist,
you have to try and antidepressants
you haven't revealed to your family or
people that care for you that
this is how you're feeling.
Then you owe it to yourself and them to
explore every possible avenue before you
take such a step and then you don't
want to deprive the world of who I've of
what you could bring to the world.
That's the other thing.
You know you have intrinsic
value and you can't just cash.
We couldn't have to an end.
You leave a hole in the
fabric of be itself.
So you know,
and why is that that I
once worked with Sam,
he was a very strange person.
He was a psychologist,
have to admit maximum
security prison and Edmonton.
And I worked with him for a while,
briefly,
very briefly up the prison itself.
And he said,
you can always commit suicide tomorrow.
And that's a very,
like,
it's a flippant statement in some sense,
but he meant it in a very serious way.
It's like you only get to decide
that once and you can put it off.
So I would say just put it off and then
put it off score and then put it off
some more and see what you can
do to put yourself together.
You don't explore every possible option.
And if,
if you're,
if you're so hopeless that
you have a suicidal plan,
which is a real sign of danger.
If you really know how you do it,
you've thought about denim and say,
tell someone for God's sake,
tell them at or goil
hospital and tell them.
And for sure trying to depress.
It's like,
what the hell do you have to lose?
So do everything you possibly can to
address the issue before you do something
like that.
Do give some thought to the people
that you're going to leave behind.
Because believe me,
you may just absolutely
wait for the moment,
the way that they will
never recover from it.
You cannot fix someone's suicide.
You're stuck with it and you think you
torture yourself from the rest of your
life.
If I would have only known if I would
have only said something different,
this particular talked to her,
her relative,
a sibling who committed suicide like
20 minutes before he committed suicide
probably after he took the pills and
she was kind of preoccupied because he
don't know that the
person at the other end,
because at the end of their Kevin and
she never forgave yourself from how it
respond.
Big Property in that last phone call,
that's a hell of a thing.
Delete someone with,
so I would say of the final thing I would
say is don't be so sure that your life
is yours to take.
You know,
you don't own yourself the
way that you own an object,
you have a moral obligation
to yourself as a,
as a locus of divine value.
Let's say.
You can treat that counseling,
that's theirs,
it's wrong.
So those are the reasons.
Exploring everything you can explore
to put yourself back on your feet,
all the things.
There's all sorts of
treatments for depression.
Don't leave the people around you with
that to suffer for the rest of the Lux.
Don't underestimate your value in the
world at don't underestimate the fact that
suicide is broad.
And so those are four reasons why you
should end your life soon or at all for
that.
So good luck.
[inaudible]
I am the harvest at Herron art school.
What's your advice for young artists
trying to shatter the conventions of
political correctness?
Well,
the first one that we probably
get the hell out of art school
[inaudible] that's actually fairly
fairly straight forward if you want to
shatter the conventions of political
correctness,
which is,
I don't take any field has been
warped or thoroughly that fine art.
Quite quite political correctness,
you know,
so,
and that's really saying something because
plenty of fields if the lenti work,
but I would say your best,
your best bet is two fold.
One is learn how to manage your
career in effective business,
like manner,
make yourself come through in terms of
putting yourself together economically.
Because if you're going to be really,
really,
really hard to monetize
statistic production.
And so if you're going to
support yourself being an artist,
you better be a sharp is this person.
There's nothing that irritates political
correct people more than that in that
development.
So you could start by that.
It's like develop yourself into a cabinet
negotiator and see if you could figure
out how you could actually
have a career as an artist.
I would say to begin with,
what you're probably going to have to
do is have an actual job and do your art
art time because,
and let us your fed globally tell it to
that even that it probably won't work.
So you could even have the jaw and then
you could work really hard on your art.
And with any luck over the
period of about a decade,
you can build connection that works.
If you could learn how the gallery
system works and you could be influential
people and you can sell your art,
maybe you could start to figure
out how to make a living.
You got to figure it out.
It's going to take like 25 30% of your
client at an absence and then you might
totally agreed with that and
that'll irritate the hell
out with your politically
correct Coles.
So because they'll say you sold out
and people who say that those are,
we never have the opportunity to sell out,
justify that absolute
moral respectability.
So it's an appalling gate.
The other thing you can do is study
great artists throughout history and then
hone your craft because there's this
idea of it's sort of a postmodern idea
that,
well,
it's all freedom of expression.
You don't need any skill.
It's like that's,
that's not,
that's not wrong.
It's like anti true.
It's not just an error.
It's like,
you know what the truth is it then you
figure out the exact opposite of that and
put that forward as a proposition.
It's like develop your skill,
you know,
they're the pain to draw the scope
to things and graphics person.
All these things develop
your skill and then,
and your discipline as well.
And then maybe you'll be able to transcend
that discipline with the skill and
produce something truly original.
But you could make yourself,
you could master the techniques of the
great artists of the past and you know,
the,
the trending types to say,
well that's all past set.
It's like,
it's not nearly as passe as their demo
opinions are going to be 10 years from
now.
Wow.
Started
an interesting guy.
You can find him on Youtube.
His name is Jonathan powershell and he's,
he was,
he was in an art school like you
at a place called [inaudible],
which is like mind boggling
late politically correct.
He was actually a pretty
good postmodernist score.
It is.
Right.
And he got completely tired
of the political correctness
that characterize the
art schools and he became a
medieval carver of orthodox icons.
That was his,
his reaction against the,
you know the training,
political politically correct orthodox
and he makes absolutely beautiful pieces.
They're worth taking a look at,
so that was Jonathan how now when he's
making youtube videos about syphilis,
Christian art that are really,
really quite good.
He's actually making a
living doing that way too.
That's so funny.
It's like,
imagine how are we there yet?
Was is that there were firsties Canadian.
Then second of all cigarettes,
if I'm liking it to get the second is
that he's making a living talking about
carving Orthodox Christian icons.
It's like no one will ever
make a living doing that.
Know he decided that he was going
to do exactly what you want to do,
which you don't want to shatter the
conventions of political correctness.
You want to be an artist
and if you are an artist,
see an artist is also someone who an
artist is someone who produces art.
It's like that's a big mistake.
And artist is someone who uses our as
a tool to investigate the structure of
reality and to extend the
human capacity to perceive.
That's where the harm ducks and artists
really,
really grieving [inaudible] skill
so that you can extend the limits of
the human relationship with beauty and
truth.
And you can transform the manner in which
people perceive so that they can see
beauty when they only soft memory before.
That's what you want to do.
And if you do that,
then you were an artist.
Feel shatter,
all sorts of conventions in the post.
And you know,
you don't want to just set
out to shatter convention.
That's like breaking the store window.
Anybody can do that.
You want to,
you want to replace them with
a better set of conventions.
That's,
that's the right way of
transcending one's conventions.
And you can do that if you,
if you discipline yourself
and to be the true artist.
Let me tell you some things about
true artists cause it's no joke.
So here's thing number one.
So Johann Johann Sebastian Bach,
first of all,
there's about five composers that dominate
the classical music world and they
own these five that's now compared to
all the composers who've ever lived.
And there their works composable half
the classical repertoire and only a tiny
proportion of the works
that they wrote our plate.
And so let's talk about bar,
cause he's one of the five,
he wrote so much music that it would
take someone 40 years just to copy it by
hand if they worked eight hour cases.
Okay,
so just think about that.
Now let's talk about a castle.
Think how many pieces
of how many paintings,
sculptures,
other objects of art
didn't because of produce.
Well,
let's see,
he had a 70 year career,
65,000 he produced three fully form
pieces of art a day for 65 years every
single day.
So it's just an,
you think about the Cuban
of value of this production,
it's like,
it's like the Cuban revalue value
quick and GDP of a decent size country.
It's absolutely,
really,
it's absolutely phenomenal.
And so if you want to be an artist
and you've got big shoes to fill,
you want to,
it's,
it's the hardest thing to be and you
have to be unbelievably disciplined at
attemptive,
ACC oriented and
exploratory and courageous,
all of that at sharp on fronts to be
an artist that you won't have to worry
about the conventions of
political correctness because
those people will be so
far behind you that you want to
be able to see the bedroom door so
[inaudible].
When will the Biblical Series
Lecture Series Continue?
December
[inaudible]
good.
I did ask you,
we just rent a small theater in Toronto.
What I'm going to start doing the,
the stories of Moses,
the exodus story is and so forth and
I'm really looking forward to that.
I have a sneaky suspicion that there isn't
anything more important that I can do
then to continue with
those biblical lectures,
but I mean this is good to
go around and talk to people.
This is a really good thing.
Great,
great.
Now,
but I think it over any
reasonable amount of time,
right?
We have full off to
continue to pursue that.
Partly because there seems to be a
real demand for it who were new gas.
So preposterous.
It's even worse.
The Jonathan Passion
situation is concerned
and I learned an unbelievable
amount of doing it.
So I'm really looking forward
to starting it up again.
So if the plan right now is
to do that December and so,
so well,
so that's,
that's the answer.
That question.
So how can we be sure
that we are not in cold?
I don't know about you.
Okay.
Convince me please.
No,
no.
Like look,
there are where there are ways
you know that you're in a cold
call just and just some little system
of belief or something like that.
Call it.
Does it called when there
are people who study colts,
they sorted the assignment.
Maybe one is a cold leader,
a chief from your family and friends.
Because one of the rules of the in a
cold is you don't get to associate with
anyone who is getting the cold.
Okay.
So are you being alienated
from your faculty and ceramics
or maybe you're giving that to yourself.
That's your brother.
So,
so if you're speaking about,
you know,
paying attention to what I've been saying,
I haven't told you to alienate
yourself from your family and friends.
I told him,
you get your bloody act together so that
you're good for your family and your
friends.
That's like the opposite of a call.
[inaudible] the
next thing is the coal of Coleen
and takes all your time and money.
I haven't taken all your money and I have
taken all your time with three primary
dimensions of call time batting zero.
So,
so,
so it's,
it's ridiculous.
It's a ridiculous,
I mean understand the comparison because
obviously there's something about this
set of ideas that has a
compounding nature of some manner.
You have every reason to be
skeptical and Leery of that.
You know,
when I tell my students at the beginning
of point maps or maybe quarters that
they should do everything they possibly
can to fight everything they possibly
can wrong about what I tell him,
that's their job.
So listen,
tell me,
because if it's wrong,
I'd like to fix it.
And so,
so I don't think that
a call can be built on,
um,
a message of fundamental
individual responsibility.
I think that's it.
You think it's a bit cold of individuals?
Well,
so it's good that you're skeptical.
It's good that you're
asking that question but,
but the code comparison isn't,
is the good one because what for the
reasons I just said the course does it as
well.
Is there reason to be skeptical of
the ideas that are putting forth?
And I would say,
well of course there is.
You should be scared.
People have ideas.
But I would also say you should give some
consideration for the fact that these
aren't precise and it's by ideas.
You know,
what I be trying to do is aggregate a set
of great ideas that [inaudible] that'd
be,
what would it be?
They'd been handed down historically.
Some of them,
it'll be discovered scientific again
to try to present those in a compelling
form to put old wine in new bottles,
let's say.
But you of course you want to be
skeptical about that at watchful time.
We,
but that doesn't mean that it's a colt
and it doesn't mean necessarily that
there's any intrinsic page.
I guess the other thing that you want
to figure out is they say part of their
fruits,
you shall know that that's the statement
in the New Testament is like if you've
been listening to these lectures and
you keep putting the principles into
practice,
you can develop a vision for your own
life and taking more responsibility and
trying to tell the truth.
What's the consequence of that?
Like when people talk to me all the time,
he said,
what things are better for me?
It's like,
well good if they're better for you.
Maybe they're a for you and your staff,
the better for you and the people
you have intimate relationships with.
It's like,
that's good,
that's good.
That's a good diagnostic
diagnostic indicator.
If you try out the ideas
and they make things better,
then well that seems to be good piece of
evidence and that's what I would watch
for and you could make up your own mind.
Stay skeptical whether you're doing it.
So,
okay,
why are you,
does message maybe
resonate with white people?
Okay.
There's no evidence for that so well,
so it's not a question
the answer properly.
Zachary ticket's gone,
we'd question that's not posed problem.
What's your evidence that it does
to make a question like that,
which is actually kind of act.
You say you should get in in short packs.
Like it's just like what's
your evidence for that?
So you don't have any evidence then?
What do you mean mainly exactly cause
we're going to be exactly about this.
It's like there's probably
a black person out here.
It's like what are you gonna do?
Go back.
Nope,
that's not a good question.
[inaudible]
what do you think is the great risk
threat towards Western society?
Your unresolved weaknesses of the errors?
Most
I need that particular,
it's like the waste is predicated on the
idea of the divinity of the individual
and that's mostly associated
with individual responsibility.
And so to the degree that you
abdicate that responsibility,
you're the threat.
It's as simple as that.
[inaudible]
is the corner for sustainable long term.
No,
I suspect that sometime in the
next 50 years I'm going to die.
Okay.
You say it would take you 3.5 more years?
I don't think it was that precise to
answer the question of Christianity Slash
God.
Slash Jesus.
Is this an honest answer out
of respect or a non answer?
Well,
it's,
it's a vague gas,
first of all.
Maybe
there's lots of things that I have to
prepared myself properly to talk about and
I'm,
I'm making,
making my way through
these biblical lectures.
I don't know how far I'll get with them
because God only knows what happens in
lights,
but I can't answer questions that I
don't want how to answer and so it is an
honest answer is out of respect.
No,
it's sounding great condition perhaps,
but mostly it's on the
recognition of my homie,
you know,
with the things that they
talked to you about tonight.
I understand.
I understand that completely because
no one understands anything completely.
I feel like I'm on solid ground.
W W with regards to what
I talked to you tonight,
like I know the literature on perception
well enough to tell you about it and to
tell you about how that's related
to emotions and motivation and to,
to lay out the relationship between
value and perception and all of that.
Because I've done the work,
you know,
I've read the papers,
I've written in the papers for that,
proud,
I've done the work and
so I'm on solid ground,
but there's lots of things
that exceed my capacity.
You know,
I'm,
I,
I do believe that are,
you know,
I,
I believe that our functional,
highly functional Western societies are
grounded in the Judeo Christian ethic.
And then fundamentally that's a religious
effort and that it makes a number of
metaphysical claims.
So I have great respect for
the ethic and for the stories,
but I'm unable to assess
the metaphysical claims.
And the reason for that is I ate urine.
I just don't know enough.
I don't understand the wellhouse way
with regard to the idea of the death and
resurrection of Christ.
Like I deemed that
psychologically and symbolically.
But that doesn't mean that I think that
exhausts the store cause I don't believe
that my knowledge exhaust the story.
But I believe,
for example,
that the part of you that's capable of
transcending tragedy and malevolence is
the part that dies.
It is reborn.
You have to leave the corrupt
parts of yourself behind.
You have to let those burn off and
you have to let your spirit be renewed
continually.
And that's an ancient story.
And I think that that has affinity with
the idea of the dying and resurrected.
See now I don't think
that exhausts the idea,
but that's as far as I've
been able to push it.
I mean in my wildest moments,
and this is speculation,
right?
This is speculation.
I think the idea that Christ died for
our sins and that mankind was redeemed is
correct,
but we still have to do the work.
It's something like that.
Now that's a benefit statement
and I don't understand the whole,
right,
right.
Because I'm talking about things that
no one can know of in some sense.
But when I pushed myself up to the
limits of my knowledge and ask,
that's the sort of
answer that comes to me.
It's like there is something
about the idea of the,
of the individual
sacrificing himself for that.
So we're taking the sins
of mankind to himself.
There's a written that's real idea.
I think that that's what people shouldn't
do is that in some senses that you're
responsible for the
catastrophe of the world.
I believe that.
And I also believe that taking
that one the fullest possible way,
we transform you beyond recognition.
And I don't know what the ultimate limit
of that is because you could say that
the story of the death and
resurrection is a living story.
Like the story of the crucifixion.
The crucifixion is suffering that can't
be exceeded in some sense because it's
the most possible suffering for
the most innocent possible person.
So that's the perfect tragedy,
right?
And so there's an idea
that whenever Christ is,
is that which takes on the tragedy
of the world in that which confronts
malevolence and overcomes it.
And I I,
that's the story of Christ.
The dessert,
for example,
the account per se,
and the story that Risa fiction is the
willingness to bear that catastrophe of
existence voluntary.
And there's an idea that doing that
produces a kind of transfiguration.
And I think that that's all true,
but I don't know what the limits of that
truth are and sort of pushing it as far
as I possibly can within
that domain acquired them.
It didn't understand me,
but I can't push it past that.
And so I know I have 300 books stacked
up at home that I need to read.
You know,
the people that be sending me to get
through this more deeply than I have been
able to get through it so far.
It's so it's,
it's recognition of my ignorance and
it's respect for the complexity of the
problem.
And I said,
well,
three,
three years or four years,
that was just an estimate based on how
quickly I'd be going through the paper
called stories.
But God only knows if I get any deeper
into it than I've already been able to
find out.
So that's my answer I guess.
Oh,
good.
A behavioral therapy seems to be the
most widely implemented theoretical
orientation in our practice
and clinical practice.
What's your primary modality
in therapy with clients?
I behaviors you get with,
because I look for simple solutions.
It's like,
well,
let's see,
before we get old
psychoanalytic on people let me,
he wanted,
he wanted to save that
and the union stuff for,
for exceptional circumstances
as far as I'm concerned.
If a client comes to me,
you know,
here's the situation.
Someone comes to me and uh,
it's because their life is going
the way that it needs to go.
Otherwise they would be there.
And so I think walnuts
decompose the problem.
Why are you,
what happened?
What,
what?
What does your unhappiness system?
So that would take a lot of conversation.
That's the diagnosis.
It's like,
well,
do you have a good friends?
How are you doing with your family?
How's your career going?
Are you are attended to your education
or you attended to your mental and
physical health?
Do you have a productive and useful
use for your time outside of work?
And Are you swamped quite temptations
like drug and alcohol use or sexual
misbehavior?
It's good way of deconstructing.
It's like how are you doing
on all those dimensions?
If you do mind future authoring program,
by the way,
which is part of this so far,
three suite,
then it will ask you all locals questions.
And so if you want to do it,
I made a discount for all of you.
He could use a cold call,
12 rules that would knock the
price down by 50% just so you know.
But we tried to,
I tried to put the essence
of useful behavioral clinic,
Ricardo Behavioral Technical Practices to,
you know,
an exercise that people
can do on the wrong.
So I want to find out exactly what is
your problem as far as your concern.
And then when we want to be respectful
at the simplest possible solutions.
And so I start from the bar.
Simple solutions,
right?
So like,
oh,
maybe you badly only shape physically
and that's contributing to your
compression.
So,
okay,
how much exercise do you do?
I'll get you to track that for a week.
Don't change anything.
Just to see how much walking you do.
So I call,
I have walked like half a mile this week.
It's like,
okay,
well how about next week?
You try walking six tenths of a mile,
right?
Incremental,
small,
incremental behavioral groups.
It's a very straightforward way to help
people and it's a pretty useful way and
you should try the simplest possible way.
And that's why I like
the behavioral approach.
Now I have clients,
usually the ones who are creative,
who also benefit tremendously from UV
and approach more symbolic approach.
They are often people dream a tremendous
and who are creative in their,
from their essence and our use that
when it's appropriate and necessary.
But that's,
that's rare.
So this is very noisy,
this thing.
So like me,
I guess.
So,
um,
let's see.
Uh,
now this could be the loudest one
because I have to stop at some point.
Um,
do you have any advice for
students studying psychology?
Yes.
Go to my website.
Yeah.
Reading list there of the best books
that I've found in my studies as a
psychologist,
there's about 20 of them.
Go read those books and that'll
put you head and shoulders ahead.
There's a lot of them are logs because
psychologists pressure the animals.
Experimental psychologists at the
neuroscience is a great strides and
understanding the way the brain works.
He really need to know
about that cause it's,
it's profound and interesting
and relevant to net.
There's a list of books written
by the great clinicians.
I think they're
unbelievably useful as well.
So we'll read all those books that if
you want to understand the psychology
that'll read that.
Yay.
So this one,
that's it.
Dr. Peterson,
what do you do to relax
and have a good time?
I come here to answer
questions from the audience.
[inaudible]
is he
your
cat litter?
Reforming cycling is
gentleman Jack,
when you were
asking me like mine in how
people get back on the world.
Well,
technical last from that,
which is,
you know I learned this
from reading 30 years ago.
You wrote this essay called placed between
the ego and the unconscious through
work of genius.
And hit warns people
who deal with are like,
what are the things you
don't confuse the ideas with cell.
You know,
like I hated watermelon.
A lot of it are some of the biological,
some of them that you have to be
very careful not to cheap credit.
No,
I'm,
fortunately I've been able to step up.
These things might be articulated
at least what I think could be,
but the ideas and the
stories vastly predate me.
They're going to be here a lot longer,
so it's nice to be able to participate
in and then to maybe help shed some light
on them I suppose.
But I'm very careful to
distinguish that from meat.
So,
and you need to do that.
And you say,
I say board of inflation,
which would be a kind of narcissistic
ready to be awesome I suppose.
And it's a very dangerous,
that's a very dangerous risk when you're
investigating these sorts of things.
But if you're a property terrified
about the negative consequences,
worst excesses,
Michael.
Well,
I
leave.
It's sort of sort of university
drew in an ethical sense.
You know he's there.
That's actually can't tell you exactly why
I was trying to day life.
Isn't he adorable?
Burdensome?
No,
because it's beyond
those trained killed us.
It's beyond us.
It's like,
well what do you do?
The base of the new Boston problems,
often impossible solution and they lost
the solution leads to voluntary bear.
That
group.
One of the strange thing is I think we
can do that and so I would say at minimum
psychologically speaking,
Christ isn't exempt flaw that.
Right.
And so something to aim at.
Of course that's it.
That's it.
What see the thing about these ideas too
is you can easily dismiss them because
it is the case that our culture has a
Judaeo Christian pollination and that
means something.
It means,
it means we all these truths to be
self evident and that's what it means.
It's the self evidence in that statement
and the self evidence has something to
do with the fact that you know
in your country and my country,
the individuals to be of this of
intrinsic value not given by the state and
weighed about intrinsic value
and worthwhile and I ended up up,
up,
up a fundamental responsibility cause
the weight of the state calls on your
shoulders.
Just have terminology.
Our culture is founded on
seems to be doing pretty well.
So that's something we can
just dispense the thought.
There's something to it.
So,
well,
well for me it's,
I don't feel that I
pushed myself up to the
limits of what I know.
And then hopefully I'll
be silent after that.
And if I learned some more
so that I actually know,
well maybe I can talk about it,
but until that time try it out,
we would actually,
oh,
not the answer.
I think what I've found
with these stores decrease,
they go,
there's no wall.
God knows how complicated picks,
really odd.
Tear,
complicated,
satisfied,
satisfaction.
The satisfaction question,
you know.
And I think that's the right answer.
Just satisfaction questions.
It's the right gas,
you know,
something like that.
So he'll want to run out
of things to do anyways.
So
very rare
art.
Yeah.
Well you never know.
Whatever possibilities.
It's certainly be gratifying to go around
from city to city doing these talks.
And so,
you know,
but that's a lovely thing.
One of the,
somebody asked him about coffee.
No,
no,
but I can tell you what I experience and
wherever I go now
I need
a touching story telling them just
want extra or something like that.
We say they tell me something
about that state your life.
Was He in a disordered state?
In one form or another?
Have sometimes severely disordered.
God,
I can't tell me the other day it was so
cold and the more I talk for 10 seconds,
he said year and a half
ago I just got out of jail.
Now I'm married,
I have a child.
I just bought my own apartment
because he was watching my lectures,
you know and so well so the reason I
broke that up cause you were talking about
law,
what's extraordinary gratified.
Whoa.
This is,
there's plenty of that to me.
So it seems like it's going quite well
and see how you can help out with that
continued,
you know my,
my set more sensible park is expected.
Just seem too crazy to be sustainable.
But
yeah,
six year old,
I would say you need to
talk to your partner,
your disciplinary scrap,
decide where do you live in is.
And be honest about that.
It's costly from what
you've told my suspicions,
allowing yourself,
MMM
[inaudible] wishes.
You've asked me at this.
Stop it.
See what happens.
My suspicions are liking
[inaudible] attitude.
You have to have a discussion about that,
but you're
getting it in front of
me and good for giving.
You finally sat and he's a Bush character.
What that means in part,
he really well socializing because a kid
like that wants to go where the lines
like it isn't just tossed.
The light can be this thick,
vague,
her kid like that.
Oh No,
no.
He wants to know where the
lions and the advantage to that.
If you can show exactly where the line is.
Perverse behavior,
keeping him on unbelievably
sophisticated social.
So that's the advantage in that
kind of emotion is what I would say.
It also sounds like he's tough enough
sphere.
My suspicions are the liking better.
My son was like,
that is a tough path.
Is that right from the right?
And one of the things that
I experienced was that,
you know,
to him and humiliate me and my wife
is Kevin Thompson candies mushed 11,
10,
okay.
For the next three days.
He gets a movement every time.
It really shocked because I
wasn't sure if that would happen,
but you know,
he's looking for
solo or
maybe
he won't buy being reasonable.
You just in the very strategies version
will be the real harm even though there
might be a lot of sparks and the like,
that's also part of the testing so that
uh,
or
no,
you feel me like so many and dealt
with things around you do all
the mask.
Most people aren't.
In that situation I have
had was tangled up Sophie,
he fixed my thinking and
we fixed one of them.
You
wait
what?
He's doing
good.
It does know there's
Christian Christianity that
might have a big
lot of that
are,
that doesn't mean it's awesome.
So I've seen people
take [inaudible] in your life,
that's for sure.
Yeah,
sure.
Rolling.
Yeah,
it's good.
The restaurant
you might want to just speed through
because it was an issue I tried to workout
in them,
which is the relationship
between disciplines.
You know,
you can think of Moses,
oh say well if you take one,
half of those other paths
are those other paths
and your potential has the
mat step your pants story.
Peter Pan Wants to stay a kid because
Penn needs every essentially it's so he
wants to retain the infinite
possibility of child
but then he ends up king in the lost boys.
Like he never,
lamb will never like this exist.
And who wants to be king was is anyways
cause he sees Kevin Hart capital is a
tire.
Right.
And the reason is the tire
just cause he's terrified.
Yeah.
[inaudible] it's already got a piece.
So how gets a target is terrified of care,
lead a panel properly with the CS and
the dollar this year or is keen in lost
boys and he doesn't get when the either,
so,
okay.
So I'm sure that
it's okay to make a decision.
You know,
you limit yourself.
But in that limiting also spam yourself.
Like if you,
this is what,
in science you can pick out a
new problem called the school
and when you start to work on that,
it expands.
You get disciplined in the Spanish,
and so you make some constraints
and the constraints of relationship,
they become stranger
career and you accept it.
It was a discipline yourself.
And the consequences of that is that
that expanse of passing the modeling.
So
potential as a child discipline,
that it's a real system of constraints,
a sacrifice 12 to sacrifice
all those other potential
pay off.
As you discipline yourself,
you start to expand out.
So
the way that I deal with that,
usually my clinical practices
implemented the best plan you have to,
well,
I'm going to wait around
for a better class.
That's not a good plan because you're
not informing yourself while you're
waiting around.
So if you implement a plan,
it's not a perfect plan.
At least you'd know why
it's a role specific.
Exactly.
What's wrong?
Damn lab.
Sorry.
We'll see.
You lose a lot less by sacrificing that.
You think that the game,
so that's what it looks
like to me moving forward.
Man.
That's right.
Well,
life's short room.
Horrible.
That's the call of adventure.
And even having stories like you know,
constantly would those God
calling them to and they do it,
you know?
But it's better than
standing where you are.
Right?
You rag magnate
and
bitter bitterness.
No,
just just one of the
ways that you could tell,
you can tell,
one of the things that council people do,
and I talked about this
like is consult you resent,
hey,
let's say that he knows
where your resentment like,
okay,
why are you present?
There's only two reasons.
One is you're used to sit and wine and
you should grow the hell up and accept
the responsibility hospital possible.
One possibility number two is you're
taking too much onto yourself without
sufficient recommends who reward.
So you're taking advantage of yourself,
where you're allowing yourself.
It's one of those too.
It's like,
okay,
so how do you figure out which one
it is all suspect the first one,
right?
Because you should always be a little
suspicious in relationship to yourself as
a little helpful that way.
And I don't mean
accessing to be skeptical,
you know,
trust.
They might say,
no one knows I need all your
taken way too much then.
Then you have to figure out how
you reward yourself for that shit.
Some of it so that you have,
because you have to be just to yourself.
You know,
I said,
when did you take on as much
responsibility as you can?
But that also means as much as pat,
if you're starting to get presented with,
that's often an assignment
you've taken on too much,
grinding yourself into the ground.
It's a bad strategy from a
sustainability perspective.
So it's all your present and see,
because you want to be able to iterate.
If you want to be able to maintain
the burden across time and resentment,
the assignment or that
you've taken on such a level,
you can't do that.
That's a partial answer to that.
So what you're saying,
monogamy,
I mean,
if you're gonna,
if you're going to accuse
someone of something,
you shouldn't use the book.
Something that someone was somewhere,
I bet if we believe
that the state should
intervene and distributed
well [inaudible] recruiters,
no.
Okay.
All sorts of immediately.
Cause I do a lot of media here.
But no,
I've never heard from Chenin four again.
But I didn't reach out to her after that.
After the first week.
Right through it.
It's a media look,
why don't we actually do this gifts.
It could actually have a conversation.
And she said,
well I'll think I'll wait until it
dies down to this trouble those down
[inaudible] it was a funny situation.
No,
I
haven't lost the big chop it up.
Five minutes.
Three Boston could like NBC,
NBC,
worst job,
anyone.
That was my calling.
It was so,
it wasn't even so much that it was,
although
it was so amateurish.
Okay.
It's not malicious,
but it would be stupid.
That's a really bad combination
because they put up the edit version,
I mean whatever the action of video.
And so then people on Youtube just said,
well
I expected more from,
you know,
and so.
So anyways,
I haven't heard back from,
and I don't really expect.
So I think it's the city
for enforcement order
this understanding that that annoys me.
Most days I,
he's been accused of a baby
to what you post modernism,
new marks that the Sukkot philosophers
know that postmodernism is skeptical
and Ben and narratives admins,
it's not commensurate Marxism.
It's like,
yeah,
I know that in that the blood post
modernists is having to seek a particular,
now
it's like they're,
they're using the ignorance
on a philosophical topic
with the actual situation
is,
is that just might the fact that
those doctrines are not commensurate,
they're juxtaposed constantly.
That's how my misunderstanding,
that's the confusion of the people
in the aggregate in academia.
So that's the most annoying.
So it's,
and it's not that,
so
[inaudible] is unbelievably unworn
cause he knew nothing about them.
So it was just cash
shooting off his mouth.
You know,
like,
I
mean I have plenty of experience
with so called minority communities.
Like I get to use that terminology
or minorities or communities,
but you know,
he doesn't know a damn thing
about what I know about,
about people who've already now
and then just assess the situation.
So,
you know,
it was,
he was very,
he had a pretty decent rhetorical kissed.
He could be charismatic
and a good sense of humor,
but a lot of cheap shots.
Like when I pushed him
on white privilege thing,
it's like,
all right,
fine ma'am,
if I net terms all he did was accurate.
That was,
uh,
an assault.
Like,
no,
it's not an assault.
We specify your damn returns,
all that,
it was a main become irritating.
It's like,
yeah,
it made me think.
And now you're irritating.
Yeah.
So,
and there's all sorts of
schools of philosophy,
physics as well that our unbelievably,
he can just,
it's very,
very,
very complicated.
And it's not a matter of truth.
Here's the truth is
associated with how you act.
There's a truth.
It's associated with what the world's is.
No one knows how
the cake is.
Katherine's identified.
These are very,
very complicated for all known.
If they seem self evident,
the only reason they seem self
evident as you the dark one.
And that's what you know,
and it seems self evident.
There's like 30 of them and they fight,
they fight like half,
so
yeah.
Hmm.
Yeah.
Uh,
well,
so,
so you know,
you said when you deconverted
that you went through your,
part of the reason for that is that
materialist atheism doesn't produce an
ethic.
That's a real problem.
And that's because there aren't
things about materialism.
There's lots of things about the truth.
You can tell that by the technology
will Howard is grass material,
but the downside of materialism
and there's technical
reasons for this stuff is
happening.
So it doesn't provide the way
guiding yourself in the world.
That's actually a huge needle.
We have guidance.
So this is part of the problem that
I have with Sam Harris for example,
is he tries to conjure an ethic
code of his materialistic atheistic.
It's like,
well,
good luck with that.
It's not obvious how to do that.
And that doesn't make me
a critic of materialism.
I'm a scientist.
I know,
I know the utility of the materialistic
view mode and I'm very much appreciative
of the tech I want you to do is produced.
But bridging that gap to
an ethic that's a big Bro.
And it's partly the reason that
it's a problem is because science,
Chase's epics power up
the argument technically.
Because what most schools can do,
if you're a science,
sorry,
get rid of the value judgements.
Well,
that's not because the system,
it's because they interfere with your
description of that lies beyond no
judgements,
but there's still the domain of value and
contentment science camp 10 women say,
well,
if you say,
it doesn't exist.
It's like,
no,
that's wrong.
It's seriously,
seriously wrong.
It even exists as an empirical phenomena,
limited universe of value are we're,
we're,
we're neurologically adapted to a world
of value to the serious flaws in that
serious flaws in them and breezy.
And it's hard on me because if you're
hearing materialistic in your outlook and
you don't have an ethos to fall,
a tie was,
and I would say that's actually proof
that there's something wrong with the
theory.
The theory makes you whole us and,
and,
and deployed to the purpose and,
and what relates to bear to the
suffering of life with no recourse.
If there's something wrong with period,
at least that's,
that's a possibility.
That's what it looks like to me.
This is,
you know,
this is something else,
but you can go on after me.
There wasn't my decision Harris,
but I think that's mostly because they
don't understand what the hell I'm
talking about.
One of the things neat you
said was the truth serves life.
That's an definition
definition.
Say Well no one truth is truth is what
you extract from an aggregation of
material fast find.
That's definition too,
but that doesn't,
it doesn't mean that that
definition is a priori.
Correct.
Because you're not just,
you're not just a fact gathering creature.
In fact,
your heart in fact cavity creature at all.
There's something that striving to live,
we need a truth that
loves to distract live.
There's no evidence that the
materialistic viewpoint provides that.
You say,
well,
it's complete.
It's like there's no evidence that it's
complete and not only best separately.
The constant revision was like 15 years
ago we found out that we didn't even
know what 95% of the universalist made up.
There's plenty of surprises yet to come.
So,
so drew is the tricky
thing then to tricky vague.
It's not self evident by any
stretch of the imagination.
You whoa,
why didn't you take them to church?
Yeah,
solve the problem.
And what's your advice for people
with young children that maybe
you're stroking the church?
It's like,
I don't know,
I be trying to puzzle it out.
Uh,
I have a friend and
this chocolate passion,
he likes,
he likes the liturgical ceremonies,
you know,
and he ever to go to the one in Seattle.
And I have to say we actually
for that I've always had,
which was I can hardly
wait til this is all,
you know.
[inaudible]
what was,
it doesn't always have,
I really wasn't a fan of school.
I had plenty of years that I was there.
And I think it's sitting in those,
in that
context brings that up.
I was so bored at school like
I to just like all my things,
like I was serious before
and I've had enough of that.
No,
I mean one of the things when I look back,
religious education,
you know,
cause I went to [inaudible],
I did learn the stories,
you know,
I was familiar enough with the story.
So they were in my imagination,
had turned out to be out.
Unbelievable work.
So I would say if you don't
bring your kids to church,
then you have a problem
with how the world of it,
where the store.
So because church has done a pretty good
job preserving the transmitting stories
and I think the stories
are necessary and useful.
So,
but I don't have a better
solution than that.
Yeah,
you put
wild.
Well you could,
but it takes a lot of
discipline with them.
You know,
it's often something that you might
want to parse off to someone else.
I mean,
maybe it can handle it.
Maybe we'll do it.
You can read to them,
so on.
But if it's a major commitment,
so yeah,
I'd like to say yes.
You know,
they learn most of the
stories could be in my house.
So maybe I managed that.
Oh,
I'm very ambivalent about that because
part of me thinks that I should go.
Probably I should go.
Okay.
Um,
you said that you,
uh,
sit here of individual be a collection
of semi-independent motivations.
And I was wondering if that scales up to
say a business with maybe like a horde
of consciousness.
They don't wonder Mike that also scale
up to say a government maybe could,
the way you conceptualize this rules
maybe apply to some of these people
wondering what should the principles
of maybe self governance be?
Maybe if we figure out maybe
that scales up
question to that brings up is how does
kind of looking inside avoid becoming
jingoistic right?
So like if,
if if the government is looking into
itself first in order to solve its
problems,
what separates that and then that same
question skills down like how do you a
and being self centered
when you're focusing on,
you see what I'm saying?
Yeah.
It becomes obvious when you scale it up,
but how does it would,
when it scales
me self centered is actually a good
solution to the problems that you,
you know,
because you might say as a collection
of semi autonomous spirits,
which is certainly the psychoanalytic
point and I think a biological viewpoint
as well.
I mean you,
you are a center that degration but you're
definitely also a collection of semi
autonomous processes.
You know,
um,
the question is how to
bring those into the unity.
You might say,
well you do that by,
I don't pick the self centered
perspective to bring those into unity,
but unity isn't,
isn't self centered.
And I think the reason for that,
and I kind of like that tonight,
you get those things operating
harmoniously together.
Just what you do is socialize a child.
They have to be serving the
child's interest now but
in a way that doesn't need
to fear what the child's interests
as it propagates across time.
And that's an unbelievably
tight set of constraints.
And you see that operating,
I didn't talk about this time.
And you see that offer
even in the animal kingdom,
you know when animals organized there
hierarchies I know that aren't going to
organize themselves in
a manner of its purity,
self-serving if they're,
if they're social animals and
they also organize them in a way.
Keeps the rights of the other elements
in mind as they organized the threats.
Yeah.
The rats are like the walls are
like the chimpanzees know so,
so that's self center need.
It doesn't need to work
parameters much less for us.
It's so,
and I think it's because things have,
I think it's because things
have to iterate across time,
headed up the rules for
successful iteration produce very,
very tight constraints on behavior
in any particular situation.
So you get an emergent debt.
What do you think that
scales the same way.
The bigger you get to say
with the company and with,
with maybe a governor like,
well I don't know because I think
things can get so fake and he just call,
you know,
I think that's the lesson
of the Tower of Babel.
It might even be the lesson up.
Uh,
the European Economic Union
might be less than that.
The United States too,
because sometimes I take
that about the last,
I think it's just to me,
certainly California
[inaudible]
so big.
It is clear that it can be
like what you do to your presidents.
It's just like
too much.
It's just too much.
Oh,
it's 300 million people.
Luckily it's the person
that's part of it.
We are addressing them to make
the units more autonomous.
No,
sorry,
this May
[inaudible] [inaudible]
I can't give you any detail just
because I don't know what he said.
Well,
I'm glad.
So then for you guys to do it and not
only you and I just had a core like we
were just kind of thing.
So the ones that,
hey,
this is amazing,
but it's also kind of mediator,
I think other folks to be hopefully
more rise to all because of one of the
[inaudible] just really special time.
Reuben,
the one thing
I
find that I'm sure you
pick up on this bill,
Sam,
about what clubs and that kind of
have that similar kind of mid eighties
about religion
and hopefully someday.
What I noticed is you said
a little bit here earlier,
but not with kind of the tone.
What's it?
Some of the times it comes across.
My concern is that he's
such an awesome time.
There's an origin,
a polarization of sharecroppers.
If some of the posts he was on paper,
um,
what's today?
And I noticed
like here,
I would see
recoverable the careful way.
Not to fix it too much on you,
but just as you're,
as you said,
these are,
these are cut of,
maybe the presentation is something,
but it is or not,
but just like seeing him kind of
doing some variation of the same.
And the reason why is that
why it's important because
I think you guys had an
opportunity to really,
just because of the nature of folks
who work with are perceived to be
conservative,
are going to the attack.
Be careful not to,
you almost have to be stark apartments
before any power was every possible
energy.
Yes.
Because sometimes they ask,
you get so cash in your life.
Luckily the people that aren't
that is to certainly go,
maybe this is,
what am I going to say
and
be that example.
That's right.
Exactly.
[inaudible] [inaudible].